LET'S GET STARTED
MORNING AND AWAY- THE J.
COMMITTEE HEARING OF FOUR APRIL.
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND NOW LET US- GET- SOME
HOUSEKEEPING MATTERS OUT OF THE
WAY. N. MY NAME'S ED CHAU ANNUM
AS THE IN THE ACTING CHAIR OF
THE COMMITTEE TODAY JOINING ME
AT THE DAIS ARE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
WANNA HOLD IT R- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAMOS AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SMITH AND- WE WAITING
FOR VICE CHAIR CUNNINGHAM TO
JOIN US. OUR OFFICE BE ENJOY BY
TONY SIMON- THE CHICKEN OF THE
ASSEMBLY JOBS COMMITTEE AND
JENNA YELLEN CONSULTANT WITH
THE REPUBLICAN CAUCUS POLICY
UNIT. AND JOINING US FROM THE
COMMITTEE- OFFICE IS NOW MISSY
FLORES COMMITTEE SEPARATE. FOR
THE ASSEMBLY JOBS COMMITTEE IF
THERE ARE ANY TECHNICAL ISSUES
WITH THE CONFERENCE LINE THE
CDC IS AVAILABLE TO ASSIST YOU
SHE CAN BE REACHED AT NINE ONE
SIX THREE ONE NINE. TWO ZERO
NINE ZERO. AND WITH THE
OVERVIEW OF THE SCHEDULE TODAY
WE HAVE A FIFTEEN BILLS. AND WE
HAVE SEVEN BILLS ON CONSENT ARE
THEY ARE ITEM STE TWO EIGHTY
FOUR SEVEN FIVE MAYOR CITY.
ITEM FOR A BI SIX THIRTY SIX
THIRTY ARAMBULA ITEM FIVE AB
ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE ARAMBULA AND
SIX EIGHTY EIGHT FORTY FOUR
GRAYSON. ITEM NINE AB TEN
THIRTY SIX. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IGOR SCEA ITEM THIRTEEN AB
FIFTEEN SEVEN SEVENTY THREE JD
COMMITTEE BILL AND ALSO ITEM
FIFTEEN AB. TEN SEVENTY TWO X.
RAYS. PLEASE NOTE THAT THIS IS
OF SOME IN OPPOSITION MEMBERS
SAW LET ME DRAW YOUR ATTENTION
TO THE LIST OF SUPPLEMENTAL
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION WHICH
EACH ONE OF YOU HAS A COPY AT
YOUR DESK. ARE THERE ALSO
COPIES ONLINE ON THE COMMITTEES
APRIL TWENTY SEVEN HEARING
PAGE. ARE THERE ARE TWENTY ONE
LETTERS- SIX BILLS ON THE
SUPPLEMENTAL SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION LIST INCLUDING
LETTERS FOR THE FOLLOWING BILLS
ITEM THREE AB FIVE THIRTY EIGHT
MURATSUCHI ITEM SEVEN EIGHTY
TEN THIRTY SEVEN GRAYSON. ITEM
TEND TO- A BEAT- ELEVEN TEN
RIVAS ITEM ELEVEN A. B.
FOURTEEN FORTY SEVEN COOLEY
ITEM TWELVE AB ELEVEN OH SIX
CERVANTES ITEM FOURTEEN A. B.
NINE OF FIFTEEN SHOOTING. UP
PLEASE BE SURE TO READ ALL OF
THE PUBLIC PARTICIPATION AND
ANTI DISRUPTION TALKING POINTS
AND THEY ARE. OKAY I HAD A LOS
WE HAVE CORN THIS IS COURT OKAY.
THE VICE CHAIR IS SO IF THAT'S
OKAY I TURN IT BACK OVER THE
DIVIDE CHAIR. GOOD MORNING
BEFORE WE BEGIN OUR BILL
PRESENTATION I NEED TO PROVIDE
AN OVERVIEW OF HOW THE PUBLIC
WILL BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN
THIS HEARING. DUE TO THE COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC WE'RE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCING
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITAL. THIS
MEANS WE'RE ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A
LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCH
AND PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING
IN PERSON. WE ARE ALSO
REQUIRING THAT MASS BE WORN A
PHYSICAL DISTANCING BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TESTIFYING WEATHER
HERE IN THE ROOM OR TO VIDEO
CONFERENCING SITE. IF YOU DO
NOT HAVE A MASS WE CAN WE CAN
PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU. WE HAVE A
FEW OPTIONS FOR WITNESS
TESTIMONY TODAY. OKAY I SEE
SOME PEOPLE IN THE ROOM THAT
MIGHT USE THIS OPTION IF ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A
BILL. PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND I
WILL ASK YOU TO APPROACH A
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. I WOULD ASK THE PUBLIC
NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE YOU
CAN EXIT THE HEARING ROOM ONCE
YOU'RE DONE TESTIFYING OR
RETURN TO YOUR SEAT. PLEASE BE
SURE TO OBSERVE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING UPON LEAVING THE
CAPITAL. FOR REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATIONS OF ANYONE'S USING THIS
OPTION- WE WILL HAVE. REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATIONS LOCATED ON
THE CAPITOL GROUNDS THOSE
WITNESSES WILL APPEAR ON SCREEN
SO MEMBERS CAN WATCH THE
TESTIMONY LIVE FROM OUTSIDE THE
HEARING ROOM. AND ALSO ASK
QUESTIONS. FOR DIALING
WITNESSES WILL BE USING A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE.
THROUGH WHICH ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC CONTEST FINAL BILL. THE
CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING
IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN.
AGAIN THAT'S EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. THE ACCESS CODE HIS.
FOUR THREE SEVEN AGAIN THAT'S.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN YOU CAN FIND THIS NUMBER
ON THE ASSEMBLY JOBS COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AS WELL AS YOUR TV
SCREEN FOR CALLING IN PLEASE
PLAN TO DO SO AT THE BEGINNING
OF THE BILL PRESENTATION THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN QUEUE. YOU'LL BE
ASKED BY THE MODERATOR TO
IDENTIFY WHETHER YOU BE
SPEAKING SUPPORTER OPPOSITION.
IF YOU'RE CALLING IN PLEASE
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE.
THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST. AND YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE SOUND
DISTORTION. AND BASED ON MY
EXPERIENCE FEW MINUTES GOBIZ
PROFESSIONS PLEASE DON'T HAVE
CHIRPING BIRDS ARE BARKING
DOGS. PLEASE ALSO BE ADVISED
THAT IF YOUR MAIN WITNESS
PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR OR
AGAINST THE BILL. YOUR PHONE
LINE REMAINS LIVE DURING THE
HEARING WHICH MEANS YOU WILL
NEED TO MEET YOURSELF UNTIL
YOU'RE CALLED ON TO SPEAK. IF
YOU'RE HAVING ANY PROBLEMS OF
THE MODERATE TELEPHONE SERVICE
YOU CAN CALL THE COMMITTEE. AT
NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE TWO
ZERO NINE ZERO. AND MERCEDES
WILL TRY TO HELP YOU. ALSO ONE
OF THE COMMITTEES ACCEPTING
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH THE
POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE WHICH IS H.
T. T. P. S. COLON. FORWARD
SLASH FORWARD SLASH AGE. A. J.
E. D. DOT ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT
GOP. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COOPERATION AS WE IMPLEMENT
METHODS TO CONTINUE TO SERVE
THE PUBLIC AND PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA WILL BE MINDFUL AND
RESPECTFUL OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERNS WE ALL FACE. DO I NEED
TO DO THE ANTI DISRUPTION OKAY.
TO ENSURE A SMOOTH HEARING WE
HAVE AN ANTI DESTRUCTION POLICY
BEFORE WE BEGIN TO HEAR THE
ITEMS ON FILE I NEED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE ASSEMBLY HAS
INCREASINGLY EXPERIENCED A
NUMBER OF DISRUPTIONS TO
COMMITTEE AND FOR PROCEEDINGS.
CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS DISTURBS
OTHERWISE IMPEDES THE ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF THE HEARING IS
PROHIBITED. THE RULES FOR
TODAY'S HEARING INCLUDE WEARING
A MASK OVER YOUR MOUTH AND NOSE
AT ALL TIMES COMPLAIN PHYSICAL
DISTANCING NO TALKING ALLOWED
NOISES FROM THE AUDIENCE.
PUBLIC COMMENT MAY BE PROVIDED
ONLY AT THE DESIGNATED TIME AND
PLACE IS PERMITTED BY THE CHAIR
PUBLIC COMMENT MUST RLATE TO
THE SUBJECT OF BILLS BEING
DISCUSSED TODAY THERE'S NO
ENGAGING IN CONDUCT THAT
DISRUPTS DISTURBS OTHERWISE
IMPEDES THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF
THIS HEARING- PLEASE BE AWARE
THAT VIOLATIONS OF THESE RULES
MAY SUBJECT YOU TO REMOVAL. OR
OTHER ENFORCEMENT PROCESS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COOPERATION IN
ADVANCE. I BELIEVE WE HAVE A
QUORUM DO IF THEY HAVE A SHOT
ALREADY. NOW OKAY. WITH THE
CHIEF CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
ROSS WE CAN ESTABLISH FOR.
CERVANTES CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM
HERE. BOERNER HORVATH HERE
BOERNER HORVATH HERE CHECK OUT
HERE CHECK OUT HERE
PETRIE-NORRIS. THREE NORTH HERE
RAMOS RAMOS HERE SMITH SMITH
HERE MR ERRY YOU HAVE A QUORUM
I WOULD HAVE CORN THANK YOU WE
ARE NOW READY TO BEGIN A
REGULAR ORDER OF BUSINESS- ITEM
ONE AB ONE OF SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS I DON'T
SEE WE'REGOING TO ITEM. TWO
WHICH IS. THAT THAT ACCENT
THREE THREE OKAY NO PROBLEM.
HEY WE GO ITEM NUMBER THREE
EIGHTY FIVE THIRTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MURATSUCHI
REMENT RELATING TO THE
CALIFORNIA AEROSPACE COMMISSION
ESTABLISHMENT- BEFORE THE
AUTHOR BEGINS BILL PRESENTATION
LET ME GIVE EVERYONE NOTICED
THE PHONE LINES ARE NOW OPEN
FOR WITNESSES TO GET IN THE
QUEUE. THE CALLING NUMBER AGAIN
IS 877-692-8957 THE ACCESS CODE
IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE. FOUR
THREE SEVEN. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SAID SHE I UNDERSTAND TO BE
ACCEPTING COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
IDENTIFIED IN COMMENTS SEVEN OF
THE BILL ANALYSIS THAT IS
CORRECT THANK YOU SIR. WITHOUT
OBJECTION WILL ADOPT THESE
AMENDMENTS AND YOU MAY BEGIN
WHEN READY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR VICE CHAIR OF MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE. THIS IS MY
THIRD ATTEMPT TO CREATE A
CALIFORNIA AEROSPACE COMMISSION
IT'LL- ONE OF THE GREAT THINGS
ABOUT OUR BEAUTIFUL STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS THAT WE ARE HOME
TO THE GLOBAL LEADERS IN THE
AEROSPACE INDUSTRY. IN A
RECENTLY WE SAW THE NEWS ABOUT
HOW. BUDGET PROPOSAL LABORATORY
SUCCEEDED IN LANDING THE MARS
ROVER ON THE PLANET MARS. YOU
KNOW WHAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE A
FEAST ON SHORTLY THIS FALL
NORTHRUP GRUMMOND IS GOING TO
LAUNCH INTO SPACE THE WEBB
SPACE TELESCOPE. THAT THEY LIKE
TO BRAG IS SO POWERFUL THAT
THEY CAN SEE THE LIGHT FROM THE
BEGINNING OF TIME. AND OF
COURSE WE ARE STILL HOME. TO
SPACEX- OVER FOUR THOUSAND.
HIGH PAYING MANUFACTURING JOBS
THAT HAVE BEEN CREATED IN THE
LAST FIFTEEN YEARS- IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND OF COURSE THEY
ARE BUILDING. THE FALCONS IN
THE DRAGON CAPSULES THAT THAT
WE ARE ALL READING IN THE
PAPERS. BUT I KNOW THAT AS THE
CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY AEROSPACE
SELECT COMMITTEE. THAT OTHER
STATES ESPECIALLY TEXAS AND
FLORIDA AND COLORADO ARE
CONSTANTLY TRYING TO LEARN AWAY
ARE- WONDERFUL AEROSPACE
COMPANIES THAT CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE YOU KNOW OVER HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF GREAT PAYING
MANUFACTURING JOBS- INTERSTATE.
AND SO WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE PROVIDING THE
PUBLIC PRIVATE. PARTNERSHIP
LEADERSHIP- TO KEEP THESE GREAT
PAYING JOBS THESE GREAT
COMPANIES- NOT ONLY FOR THESE
MARQUEE COMPANIES- LIKE SPACEX
AND JPL. BUT ALSO THIS SMALL
AND MEDIUM SIZE MANUFACTURERS-
THE SUPPLY CHAIN THAT CONTINUES
TO OPERATE- HERE IN OUR GREAT
STATE. WE HAVE A CALIFORNIA
FILM COMMISSION WE HAVE A
CALIFORNIA TRAVEL AND TOURISM
COMMISSION. WE SHOULD HAVE A
CALIFORNIA AEROSPACE
COMMISSION. SO I'D LIKE TO-
INVITE I HAVE TWO WITNESSES
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
ALEX BY AND THE DIRECTOR OF THE
INSTITUTE OF TRANSPORTATION
STUDIES AT UC BERKELEY. AND
JUDY KRUEGER A SENIOR DIRECTOR
AT THE LOS ANGELES ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION. THANK
YOU MR MODERATOR UNDERSTAND WE
HAVE DR BIDEN OBEYED IN SYDNEY
ON THE CONFERENCE ON. HOW
EXPLAINS PICKING HERE YEP CAN
YOU HEAR ME YEAH YOU MAY BEGIN
READY SIR. OKAY BOB SHOULD I
SPEAK NOW YES. THANK YOU UP
ABOUT MURATSUCHI FOR THE
INVITATION TO TESTIFY TODAY AND
I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE ACTING
COMMITTEE CHAIR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHAU AND BY CHANCE ON THE
NUMBER CUNNINGHAM FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ALEX FIND
FIVE WORK FOR YOU TO BERKELEY
AT THE PROPERTY- OF ELECTRICAL
ENGINEERING AND COMPUTER
SCIENCE. AT BERKELEY OF THE
DIRECTOR OF AEROSPACE PROGRAMS
IN ADDITION TO THE INSTITUTE OF
TRANSPORTATION STUDIES AS WELL
AS MENTIONED EARLIER I OVERSEE
THE CONSTRUCTION OF AEROSPACE
ECONOMIC ACTIVITIES ON CAMPUS
IN PARTICULAR WOULD NOT THE
INTERNET MOFFETT FIELD WITH
WHICH UC BERKELEY AFTER ENTERED
A LEASE AGREEMENT TO DEVELOP A
NEW AEROSPACE PROGRAM. IF YOU
THAT EXPECTING TODAY ON BILL A.
B. FIVE THIRTY EIGHT OR MY OWN-
THEY'RE NOT THAT. OF THE
AVERAGE OF CALIFORNIA. THE
ACCOMPLISHMENT OF AN AEROSPACE
COMMISSION OF. BY BILL IS IN
OPINION IF CENTRAL TELEPHONE.
FIRST IT WILL EMPOWER THE OF
THE- TO. THE NEXT PHASE SPACE
EXPLORATION. BY TO A LOCAL
GOING INDUSTRY. IT WILL HELP
BRING A NEW COMPANY TO
CALIFORNIA TO SUPPORT THIS
GROWTH. BUT CAN. IT WILL ENABLE
THE NEXT ANALYTICS TECHNOLOGY
REVOLUTION IN CALIFORNIA. OVER
THE NEXT DECADE AUTOMATED
ELECTRIC LIGHT WILL EMERGE OF
THE NEW PARADIGM. ULTIMATELY
LEADING. TO AUTOMATED FLIGHT.
THIS COMMISSION WILL BE
ESSENTIAL TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS REVOLUTION HAPPENED IN
CALIFORNIA. BY QUITTING
CRITICAL SYSTEMS. INTO A
COMPELLING PARTICULAR. THIRD
FIELD. AN INTO PRE FOR PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS TO GROW
THE CRITICAL MASS OF WORKFORCE
FOCUSING ON THE LEADING THE
WORLD IN THESE NEXT STEPS OF
ERRATIC THE METRONOMIC. IN
PARTICULAR WILL LEVERAGE THE
VERY LONG WHAT BRANCH OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
STANFORD CALTECH AND THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY. IN
CONCLUSION THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
THE- COMMISSION WELL THAT
INCREASE CALIFORNIA AEROSPACE
LEADERSHIP IN THE US AND IN THE
WORLD. IT WILL ENABLE
CALIFORNIA TO SPEAK THE GLOBAL
LEADER AND SPACE
INSTRUMENTATION TECHNOLOGY AND
IT WILL ALSO ENABLE CALIFORNIA
TO RISE TO THE CHALLENGE OF
AUTOMATED FLIGHT AND MAKE IT
THE WORLD'S LEADER IN GREEN
REVOLUTION THEREBY ALSO
CONTRIBUTING TO IT AMBITIONS
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS. IT WILL
UNABLE THE CREATION OF MORE
JOBS IN THE AEROSPACE INDUSTRY
AND FINALLY IT WILL ENABLE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A MORE SKILLED.
WORK FORCE BY A UNIQUE
CONDUCTIVE OF IT COULD
OCCASIONAL COOK THEM AN
INDUSTRY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY AND ARE YOU
ATTENTION AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE ARTS OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU SIR
MISTER MODERATOR UNDERSTAND WE
ALSO HAVE MS JUDY KRUEGER ON
THE CONFERENCE LINE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING. YOU MAY
BEGIN RUN READY- ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU AND- THIS IS JUDY
KRUEGER SENIOR DIRECTOR AT THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION AND I
WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BIRTH TO TREAT FOR THE
INVITATION TO SPEAK AND THANK
YOU THANK YOU TO THE VICE CHAIR
OF THE COMMITTEE. WE WANTED ON
RECORD TO STRONGLY SUPPORT AB
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT FIVE. THAT
WOULD ESTABLISH THE CALIFORNIA
AEROSPACE COMMISSION. WE SEE
THE AEROSPACE AND SPACE
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA AS EIGHT
FEET INDUSTRY THAT WILL BEAT
AND ECONOMIC RECOVERY IN THESE
CHALLENGING AND TRYING TIMES.
IT'S BEEN A STRONG LEADER ABOUT
FOR DECADES AS WE ALL KNOW AND
AS THE GLOBAL LEADER THIRTEEN
QUITE THERE'S NO. OTHER
INDUSTRY AEROSPACE AND SPACE
INDUSTRY QUITE LIKE WHAT WE
HAVE IN CALIFORNIA. NOT ONLY
WITH OUR- AIRPORT SPACES BUT
ALSO THE COMMERCIAL AND-
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE BOTH
COMMERCIAL AND SPACE
EXPLORATION THAT WE HAVE BEEN
IN CALIFORNIA WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE- THE COMMISSION. BE
ESTABLISHED TO SUPPORT AND
NURTURE AND GROW THAT STRONG
ECOSYSTEM THAT CONTRIBUTE TO
OVER TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN
THOUSAND AEROSPACE JOBS AND-
MULTIPLIER JOBS IN THE REGION.
AND THESE ARE GOOD PAYING JOBS
M. WITH ABOUT A HUNDRED AND SIX
THOUSAND PER YEAR ON AND PAY.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SPOKE ABOUT
THIS EARLIER- THERE ARE MANY
OTHER STATES WHO HAVE AEROSPACE
COMMISSION AND WE HAVE HEARD
FORMER AEROSPACE AND SPACE
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA THAT
THEY WOULD. APPRECIATE HAVING
AN ARAB. THE COMMISSION THAT.
YOUR YOUR ECOSYSTEM AND DOES
THAT CALIFORNIA SUPPORT AND
ENCOURAGES THE AEROSPACE AND
SPACE INDUSTRY ANECDOTALLY I
USED TO WORK FOR THE STATE OF
MICHIGAN AND WORKED FOR AND-
RECRUITED COMPANIES INTO
MICHIGAN- UNDER THE MICHIGAN
AEROSPACE ASSOCIATION. A STATE
SPONSORED ASSOCIATION WHO I
KNOW WELL THE COMPETING FACTORS
WE HAVE A BEAUTIFUL STATE AND
WE HAVE A WONDERFUL THE RISING
AEROSPACE INDUSTRY WITH
SPILLOVER EFFECTS INTO ELECTRIC
VEHICLES AND THE- DIGITAL MEDIA
AND ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY IN
THE CREATIVE ECONOMY WE HOT
HERE. IN ITS ECONOMIC
DEVELOPERS WE WOULD LOVE TO
SUPPORT AB FIVE THIRTY EIGHT
AND- SEE IT PASSED AND
ESTABLISHED AEROSPACE.
COMMISSION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CRUZ MISTER MODERATOR IS OUR
ELSE I WOULD NOW TURN TO THE
HEARING ROOM TO SEE IF ANYONE'S
HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT IN
PERSON SAYING NO ONE- MISTER
MODERATOR IS OR ANYONE ELSE ON
THE CONFERENCE LINE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU WE WOULD LIKE
TO STATE SUPPORT FOR AB FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE.
GANNETT'S ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
AT THIS TIME PLEASE. YOU HAVE A
LINE IN Q. OVER NINE THIRTY ONE
THREE ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING SHANE GUSMAN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CONFERENCE A MACHINIST IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
THERE ARE NO OTHER LINES INTO
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU NOW
WILL TURN TO THE HEARING ROOM
TO SEE IF ANYONE'S HERE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SAYING NO
ONE- SERGEANT IS THEREANYONE
AT THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION
TO SPEAK. IN SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION. INDICATION IS NO.
WE WILL MOVE TO- MISTER
MODERATOR IS THERE ANYONE ON
THE CONFERENCE LINE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU TO STAY
IN A POSITION OF OPPOSITION TO
AB FIVE THIRTY ME PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE.
AGAIN THE OPPOSITION TO FIVE
THREE EIGHT. PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY. ZERO AN ONLINE SOME QUEUE
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR- WILL BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE FOR DISCUSSION THE
NEW MEMBERS LIKE TO ASK
QUESTIONS MS BURNER HARBAUGH.
YES I WOULD LIKE TO THANK A-
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD I THINK MANY
PEOPLE DON'T REALIZE THAT
ACTUALLY WENT TO UC BURST
BERKELEY TO STUDY ASTROPHYSICS
TO BE AN ASTRONAUT- THAT DIDN'T
WORK OUT- BUT I DO BELIEVE THAT
THE THAT CALIFORNIA HAS THE
TALENT POOL. TO CREATE THIS
ECOSYSTEM AND ENSURING THAT
WERE COMPETITIVE AND IN NO NON
IN THE FUTURE IS REALLY
IMPORTANT I THINK YOUR BILL
WILL BE. VERY IMPORTANT TO
MAKING SURE THAT HAPPENS SO-
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO MOVE THE
BILL. THANK YOU THERE'S A
MOTION BY MISTER ABBAS SECONDED
BY MR SMITH- THAT MS
PETRIE-NORRIS WOULD JUST LIKE
TO. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
I THANK YOU AS WELL TO THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD- AS YOU SAID- SPACE
REALLY IS A VITAL INDUSTRY FOR
CALIFORNIA AND- I THINK THAT AS
WE LOOK FORWARD GOING TO BE
REALLY INTENTIONAL ABOUT
CULTIVATING FUTURE GROWTH AND
INCENTIVIZING FUTURE GROWTH IN
THIS INDUSTRY. I'M I DO HAVE
ONE QUESTION SO I THINK AS YOU
MENTIONED THIS IS YOU'VE COME
TRIED A SIMILAR PROPOSAL A
COUPLE TIMES AND I THINK EITHER
WAS IT THIS BILL OR A SIMILAR
BILL THAT WAS VETOED BY
GOVERNOR BROWN. HE SAID THAT
CONNECTS IT CREATES A
BUREAUCRACY THAT THAT'S NOT
NECESSARY CAN YOU JUST I GUESS
SPEAK TO THAT SURE AT AN END
CLEAR FIVE YOU KNOW WHY THIS IS
IN FACT IN THE THINK IS
NECESSARY I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THAT QUESTION- SO- THE
ISSUE OF- WHO'S GOING TO PAY
FOR THE COMMISSION- AND HOW
MUCH HAS BEEN. I. N. ISSUE ARM.
YOU KNOW WELL PLUS OUR OUR
PREVIOUS GOVERNOR- BROWN FOR
HAVING A REPUTATION FOR BEING
FRUGAL HE'S ALWAYS A- YOU KNOW.
A BUREAUCRACY HOCK IN TERMS OF-
YOU KNOW HE HAD A RECORD OF NOT
WANTING TO CREATE NEW OF BODIES
ARM BUT I. YOU KNOW I I'M
FEELING VERY CONFIDENT ABOUT
THIS BILL BECAUSE- WE HAD A
BREAKTHROUGH DEVELOPMENT- WHEN
WE- YOU KNOW RECEIVE THE
SUPPORT AND THE INTEREST FROM.
THE UC BERKELEY INSTITUTE OF
TRANSPORTATION STUDIES- WHERE-
I I'D LIKE TO PUT THIS
COMMITTEE UNNOTICED THAT TO. IN
A WHILE THE BILL CURRENTLY
TALKS ABOUT. CREATING A NEW
DIRECTOR OF THIS COMMISSION YOU
KNOW WE'RE WE'RE HOPING THAT-
THAT- THIS SHOULD BE AN ALL
VOLUNTEER COMMISSION WHERE THE
STAFFING SUPPORT FOR THE
COMMISSION WOULD BE PROVIDED BY
THE UC BERKELEY INSTITUTE FOR
TRANSPORTATION STUDIES. SO THAT
WE WOULD ELIMINATE. YOU KNOW
ANY NEED FOR IN ANY NEW STAFF-
FOR THIS POSITION I HOPE THAT
THE CONSULTANTS WHO WILL- KEEP
THAT IN MIND IF WE DO- ARE ARE
ABLE TO MAKE THAT AMENDMENT TO
AS WE GO FOR A FORWARD IN THIS
PROCESS BUT- YOU KNOW WE'RE
WE'RE HOPING THAT IF WE CAN.
YOU KNOW JUST KEEP IT TO A
BASICALLY AN ADVISORY
COMMISSION- TO GUIDE. INTO
STATE POLICY ON ON- ATTRACTING
RETAINING AEROSPACE- JOBS AND
COMPANIES. WITH MINIMAL
BUREAUCRACY THAT- WE CAN.
SUCCEED IN GETTING GONNA THEY
THE GOVERNOR'S SIGNATURE THIS
TIME. WELL THANKS YEP THANKS
FOR THAT AND THANK YOU ALSO FOR
YOUR JUST LONG STANDING.
COMMITMENT FIVE TWO THIS
INDUSTRY FOR CALIFORNIA- AND
GUESTS WILL BE VERY HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BALLOT AND- THANK
YOU AYE AYE I WOULD LIKE TO
INVITE ANYONE. WHO'D LIKE TO BE
A CO AUTHOR ON WITH TO REALLY
APPRECIATE TO. ADDING YOUR NAME
TO THE BILL ALSO THANK YOU.
I'LL BE HAPPY TO BE ADDED AS A
CO AUTHOR THANK YOU. YES AS
WELL THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT-
EXERCISE WHEELCHAIRS. THIS IS
A- IS A TRIPLE BAGGER FOR ME
AS- THE MEMBER THAT REPRESENTS
VANDENBERG AIRFORCE BASE WHICH
HAS OF BURGEONING. COMMERCIAL
SPACE INDUSTRY GOING ON WITH
THE PRIVATE SECTOR
COLLABORATING. WITH GOVERNMENT
WHICH IS GREAT. AND SOMEBODY
WITH A DEGREE FROM BERKELEY.
AND I HAVE A LARGELY UNUSED
PHYSICS BACHELOR'S DEGREE.
DON'T GO TO LAW SCHOOL AFTER
YOU GET A DEGREE IN PHYSICS
WILL NEVER USE PHYSICS TO BE A
LAWYER. BUT ANYWAY I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL I APPRECIATE
YOUR HARD WORK. AND DILIGENCE
AND- BEING A CHAMPION FOR THEIR
ASSIDUOUS INDUSTRY. LOVE BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR AND I
THINK WE HAVE MOTION SECOND
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THANK YOU
ITEM THREE AB FIVE THREE EIGHT
THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED. TO APPROPRIATIONS
FASTER CUNNINGHAM. VICE CHAIR
CUNNINGHAM HI BOERNER HORVATH.
AS A MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH HI
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAD ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CAL I CAN'T REMEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS THE FARM VETRI
NORRIS I ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS
SILVERADOS HI ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SPENT- YES I'D LIKE TO BE ADDED
AS A CO AUTHOR TO AND YES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SMITH I. HER VOTE IS THE
SIX ZERO AB FIVE THIRTY IS OUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THE MOTION
WAS DUE PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
FOR THE RECORD RIGHT YEAH IT
HASN'T MEANT IT THANK. NEXT WE
WILL MOVE TO- FILE ITEM SEVEN
SEEING MR GRAYSON HERE THANK
YOU SIR. F. FILE ITEM SEVEN IS
AB TEN THIRTY SEVEN- BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON
RELATING TO THE DIGITAL
CONSTRUCTION TECHNOLOGY.
TECHNOLOGIES BEFORE THE AUTHOR
BEGINS LET ME REMIND EVERYONE
AGAIN THE PHONE LINES ARE NOW
OPEN FOR WITNESSES TO GET IN
THE QUEUE THE CALL IN NUMBER IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAYSON UNDERSTAND TO BE
ACCEPTING COMMITTEE AMNDMENTS
IDENTIFIED IN COMMENTS SIX OF
THE BILL ANALYSIS. YES THANK
YOU SIR. WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL
DROP THESE AMENDMENTS- YOU MAY
BEGIN ROOM WHEN READY. THANK
YOU MR VICE CHAIR AND ALSO
MEMBERS I DO WANT TO THANK
COMMITTEE STAFF IN PARTICULAR
THE CHIEF CONSULTANT. FOR JUST
BEING WONDERFUL TO WORK WITH
VERY PROFESSIONAL AND ALL THE
INPUT AND ATTENTION GIVEN TO
THIS BILL SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND ONCE AGAIN I AM
ACCEPTING AMENDMENTS OFFERED BY
THE COMMITTEE AB TEN THIRTY
SEVEN WILL HELP US MAXIMIZE TAX
DOLLARS. M. DELIVER CIVIL
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS MORE
EFFICIENTLY AND EFFECTIVELY BY
CREATING GUIDELINES FOR DIGITAL
CONSTRUCTION MANAGEMENT
TECHNOLOGIES OR HE CONSTRUCTION
TO BE UTILIZED BY THE STATE.
CONSTRUCTION MANAGEMENT
TECHNOLOGIES OR TOOLS OUR CLOUD
BASED PLATFORMS USED ON
CONSTRUCTION SITES AND SUPPORT
DIGITIZE CONSTRUCTION
ADMINISTRATION MANAGEMENT AND
COLLABORATION. THESE
TECHNOLOGIES ARE USED IN PLACE
OF TRADITIONAL PAPER BY OWNERS
AND CONTRACTORS FOR THE
PURPOSES OF PROJECT SITE
PREPARATION FIELD EXECUTION
CONSTRUCTION PROJECT MANAGEMENT
DOCUMENT MANAGEMENT AND
COORDINATION COLLABORATION
AMONG STAKEHOLDERS. STATE
DEPARTMENTS OF TRANSPORTATION
ACROSS THE COUNTRY ARE NOW
USING DIGITAL CONSTRUCTION
MANAGEMENT TECHNOLOGIES TO
REDUCE PROJECT COSTS ACCELERATE
PROJECT DELIVERY ENHANCE
CONSTRUCTION SAFETY AND BUILD
MORE INNOVATIVE RESILIENT AND
SUSTAINABLE INFRASTRUCTURE.
THROUGH THE DEPLOYMENT OF
CONSTRUCTION MANAGEMENT
COMPANIES MICHIGAN DOT
ESTIMATES TWELVE MILLION IN
SAVINGS AND ELIMINATION OF SIX
MILLION PIECES OF PAPER
ANNUALLY AND UTAH DOT IS SAVING
NINETEEN POINT FIVE MILLION
ANNUALLY. HERE IN CALIFORNIA
THE CONTRA COSTA TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY AND THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO HAVE ALSO UTILIZE
THESE TECHNOLOGIES TO
SIGNIFICANTLY ELIMINATE PAPER
USE AND HELP DEVELOPERS
CONTINUE BUILDING DURING COVERT
NINETEEN SAFETY RESTRICTIONS.
THERE IS EVIDENCE OF GREATER
COST SAVINGS TIME AND
SUSTAINABILITY BENEFITS THIS SO
SHE DID WITH THE EMPLOYMENT OF
CONSTRUCTION MANAGEMENT TOOLS
UNIFORMLY ACROSS ORGANIZATIONS
AND PROJECT DELIVERY
STAKEHOLDERS. THE PROBLEM IS
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS ONLY
IMPLEMENTED THESE TOOLS IN A
FRAGMENTED MANNER AB TEN THIRTY
SEVEN WILL FIX THIS BY CREATING
STATEWIDE GUIDANCE AND POLICIES
FOR THE INTEGRATION AND
DEPLOYMENT OF DIGITAL
MANAGEMENT TECHNOLOGIES FOR THE
USE ON STATE CIVIL
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS. I'M
PROUD TO OF ORGANIZATIONS SUCH
AS THE BUSINESS SOFTWARE
ASSOCIATION AND CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT AND HAVE
NO OPPOSITION. MY WITNESSES ARE
PROFESSOR RAMANI- DR RAMANI
FROM UC DAVIS AND LAWRENCE
GAIDEN POLICY DIRECTOR OF C. M.
T. H. THANK YOU SIR. THANK YOU
MR MODERATOR UNDERSTAND WHERE
PROFESSOR OF BONNIE ON THE LINE.
YES I AM ON THE LINE CAN I
SPEAK NOW YES BEGIN WHEN READY
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING YEAH
BUT THE VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I THANK YOU
ATTENDED MEMBER GRAYSON SLOWING
BY JIMMY AT. TO TESTIFY ON AB
TEN THIRTY SEVEN DEALING WITH
DIGITAL. CONSTRUCTION
TECHNOLOGY MY NAME IS BARBARA
BONNIE AND THE DISTINGUISHED
PROFESSOR OF MECHANICAL
ENGINEERING AT UC DAVIS. AND CO
DIRECTED CENTER ON HIGH THE.
CONSTRUCTION AND MAINTENANCE
TECHNOLOGY. I HEALTH CARE THE
OF TRANSPORTATION. DEVELOP ITS
YOU GO. PORTANTINO OF TECHNO.
VIEW THE COMPLETE TO ALTHOUGH
THE MY OWN AND NOW OF THE WITH
THE. FOR AS YOU HAVE BEEN A
STATE. EFFECT NOT CAN REDUCE
COSTS ACCELERATE PROJECT
DELIVERY AND HAVE WHAT THE PAID
HE- ALSO PUT WHY FOR AN THOUGHT
THE NUMBER AND BUILDING AND JOB
MORE. IMPROVES MORE MORE COURSE
HIM I'M BETTER PAY. UP TO
EIGHTEEN SCHOOL JUNIOR COLLEGES
WHO EACH THE TO WORK. FOR
VETERANS DISSECTION YOU NEED
FOR CONSTRUCTION PROJECT AT THE
VERY. DOT THE DOCTRINAL CARBON.
IN HAND AND YOU USE MAINTENANCE.
AND PROVIDE FOR INPUT AT THE
MONEY. TRUMP NON BASED ON MY
ONLY IN. THAT YOU TO ON THE OR
ROI YOU WOULD RAIN FROM TWO ONE
AT TO SEVEN SEVEN WE DON'T HAVE
A UP SLIGHTLY OVER FOUR AND A
HALF FROM AND COULD. TO PROJECT
AND CONSTRUCT MATTER AND THE-
IT IS INTERESTING THAT ALTHOUGH
OF THE IN OVER ON DEVELOPMENT.
HAVE BEEN IN THE U. S. I'M
HOPING COUNTY FOR. IT IS ONLY
SUCH AS JAPAN AND FRANCE GEN
AND- WHAT MADE MORE PROGRESS IN
INTEGRITY OF THE STATE. AND
BETTER FROM. THE QUESTION IS
WHY. INDEED YOU IT'S TO HIGH
WILL BE THE MY MANAGER ON DUTY
MAY IN PUBLIC AND SECTOR. THE
STOCK AGAINST OUR FRONT COST
SUCH TO. BASED ON THE SHOW TERM
I. AND THERE COULD BE NOT
MATERIALIZE THE LONG TERM AND
THE STREETS BENNETT. SIR IF YOU
GET A BALLOT RAPPER YOUR TEST.
IT GETS ON YOUR ACCOUNT ARE
MORE VERY. TO AB TEN THIRTY
SEVEN PUT YOU FOR YOUR SIMILAR
PASSED PROVIDING BEACON BENEFIT
OF TECHNOLOGY THAT MOST HAVE
DEVELOPED HERE IN TOWN POLICE.
IT ALSO GAVE THE VERY POOR IN
THE FUTURE APPLICATION AND THEN
OF THE OF A LIFE FOR OUR FUTURE
INTELLIGENCE FIVE G. BLOCK. AND
DIGITAL WILL BE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND YOUR POTENTIAL BY.
GO HERE THANK YOU SIR MISTER
MODERATOR WE HAVE MISTER GAIDEN
THE LINE. YES YOU GOT GIVE ME.
YES GO AHEAD- GOOD MORNING-
THIS GERMAN DOES GAME POTS WORK
WITH ME- CALIFORNIA AFFECT SO
WE PROUD TO SUPPORT AB TEN
THIRTY SEVEN WHICH WILL
LEVERAGE READILY AVAILABLE
DIGITAL CONSTRUCTION MANAGEMENT
TECHNOLOGIES TO INCREASE
EFFICIENCY SUSTAINABILITY COST
SAVINGS AND UP IMPROVE PROJECT
DELIVERY TIME TO PROJECT
QUALITY I'M SEEN HERE REPRESENT
OVER FOUR TO BUSINESSES FROM
THE ENTIRE MANUFACTURING
SPECTRUM I'M GENERATING MORE
THAN TOWARD AN EIGHTY EIGHT
BILLION EVERY YEAR EMPLOY MORE
THAN ONE POINT THREE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS. OF MAYBE TEN
THIRTY SEVEN REPRESENTS POLICY
THAT WILL KEEP CALIFORNIA'S
MANUFACTURING INDUSTRY AT THE
FOREFRONT OF OUR GLOBAL
LEADERSHIP INNOVATION BY
INCREASING OUR ABILITY TO
PRODUCE TO COMPETE AS WE
CONTINUE OUR ECONOMIC RECOVERY
FROM KOBE NINETEEN CALIFORNIA'S
BONTA PATERNITY THAT DRIVE
TOWARD OUR STATE GOALS OF
PUTTING CALIFORNIA BACK TO WORK
REDUCING COST OVERRUNS AND
BUILDING A MORE SUSTAINABLE AND
RESILIENT INFRASTRUCTURE AT
OFFICIALLY AS POSSIBLE. AND
STATE DISTRIBUTES FEDERAL
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING OR
LEVERAGES STATE BONTA FINANCED
A PROJECT OR PROJECTS SHE SEEK
TO MAXIMIZE SECTOR DOLITTLE
DRIVE THE BEST POSSIBLE VALUE
FOR ITS INVESTMENT DEPLOYMENT
OF DIGITAL CONSTRUCTION
MANAGEMENT TECHNOLOGY WILL
FURTHER ACCELERATE
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECT DELIVERY
TIME REDUCE COSTS AND WASTE AND
DEVELOP MORE SUSTAINABLE
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVE WORKER
SAFETY ENABLE REMOTE WORK WHILE
ENHANCING RESILIENCY. USUALLY
DO THE USE OF THE DIGITAL
FOURTH PROGRAM TO OFFER
TREMENDOUS VALUE AND IT IS TIME
THE CALIFORNIA ME IMPLEMENT THE
VIEWS OF THIS TOLD YOU MANNER-
ACCORDING TO THE UNITED STATES
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION
FEDERAL HIGHWAY ADMINISTRATION
THE TECHNOLOGY HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFULLY UTILIZED BY
VARIOUS STATE DEPARTMENTS CLEAN
MICHIGAN MINNESOTA FLORIDA
TEXAS- WITH CONSTANT I WOULD
NOT MENTIONED EARLIER THE-
MICHIGAN DEPARTMENT
TRANSPORTATION THAT I THINK
PROXIMALLY TWELVE MILLION. AND
ADDED EFFICIENCY AND OVER SIX
ME PIECE OF PAPER ANNUALLY BY
USING ELECTRONIC DOCUMENT
STORAGE ARS ONE BEING
CONSTRUCTED PROGRAMS WHILE
REDUCING IT AVERAGE CONTRACT
MODIFICATION PROFIT IN TIME FOR
THIRTY DAYS AFTER THREE DAYS ON
CALIFORNIA MANY PRESSURE LOOK
FOR DEPARTING WITH THE STATE'S
SUPPORT CONSTRUCTION MANAGEMENT
TECHNOLOGIES TELL CALIFORNIA
CREEK BENJI AND PRODUCTION ALL
WHILE SAVING COSTS FOR THE
STATE PROPERTIES REASON TEAM
TAKE THE COURTS AB. TEN THIRTY
SEVEN OR QUESTIONS. ABOUT I
CAN'T. THANK YOU SIR TWO
MINUTES ON THE WORLD- THERE
ANYONE THE HEARING HERE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT THE BILL. C.
NO ONE LET'S MOVE TO THE REMOTE
TESTING STATION SERGEANT IS
THERE ARE ARE ANY IN THE REMOTE
TESTING STATION. SEEING END TO
OF THAT HI MISTER MODERATORS
ANYONE ELSE ON THE CONFERENCE
LINE READY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL HUMANE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
AGAIN THAT'S ONE ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE. YOU HAVE A FEW LINES
IN KING. LEVINE LOCAL FIRST IN
LINE THIRTY FIVE THREE FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
ALEXANDER GOOD ON WITH
LIGHTNING GROUP ON BEHALF OF
OTHER DEATHS IN SUPPORT. NEXT
NEXT WE CAN GO TO LINE FORTY
SIX FOUR SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING KELLY HEAD ON
BEHALF OF THE BUSINESS SOFTWARE
SENSATION IN SUPPORT. AND WE DO
HAVE A THIRD LINE IN Q. LINE
TWENTY SEVEN TWO SEVEN YOUR
LINE OPEN. TWENTY SEVEN DID YOU
WANT TO STATE YOUR POSITION.
WHEN OUR SPOTS FROM THAT LINE-
TURN ON LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS
NOW IT'S TIME TO HEAR FROM THE
OPPOSITION IS ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM HERE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION SAYING NO ONE. A
SERGEANT IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. SEEING NO
ONE. MISTER MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE CONFERENCE LINE
THAT WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. WE LIKE TO STATE A
POSITION OF OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
THAT'S ONE OF THEM ZERO. THANK
YOU TURN ON LINES IN Q. THANK
YOU MR MODERATOR MEMBERS IT'S
NOW TIME FOR DISCUSSION TO ANY
MEMBERS WISH TO ASK QUESTIONS.
IS BEACH NORTH THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR. AB SO I REALLY LIKE
THIS PROPOSAL I THINK IT'S ODD
IT'S COMPELLING YOU JUST HAVE
ONE QUESTION BECAUSE I THINK-
WE ALSO. SHARE A GOAL OF
ENSURING THAT AT SMALL
BUSINESSES AND JUST WORK IN
BUSINESSES OWNED BY. WOMEN
MINORITIES- ENJOY A SHARE OF
STATE CONTRACTING DOLLARS- HOW
DO WE ENSURE THAT AS WE
IMPLEMENT THESE NEW
REQUIREMENTS WHICH I THINK MAKE
IT HAD A SNSE. THAT THOSE
FOLKS DON'T GET. LEFT BEHIND-
ABOUT STOP. I THINK THAT'S A
GREAT POINT DID YOU BRING UP OF
THOSE- THOSE POLICIES ARE
ALREADY IN PLACE. SO I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT THIS- THIS BILL
WOULD INTERFERE WITH THAT
HOWEVER. I THINK IT WOULD BE
WISE TO DOUBLE CHECK THAT AS WE
MOVE FORWARD AND IF ANYTHING IT
WOULDN'T HURT TO HELP CODIFY
THAT AS WE BRING IN THIS POLICY
AS WELL. GREAT YEAH AND I THINK
IT DID FOR ME AT THIS SORT OF
TRIGGERED YES FOR THE LA PI
THINK AS WE'RE IMPLEMENTING. AT
FORWARD THINKING POLICIES
PROPOSALS WITH AND I THINK
PROBABLY TO COUPLE THAT WITH
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO ENSURE
THAT OUR- OUR SMALLEST
BUSINESSES ABSOLUTE CONTINUE TO
ENJOY THAT AND MOVE FORWARD
SEPT THANK YOU AND- AND IF THE
BILL'S BEEN MOVED. ALREADY HAS
IT YES OKAY. THAT HELPS I'M
HAPPY TO. THANK YOU. YOU MISTER
CHOP THANK YOU MISTER. IF I
COULD- FOLLOW. WITH A COUPLE OF
A- QUICK QUESTION TO MAKE TO.
FOR THOUGHT ALL THANK YOU FOR
THIS. MAYBE THE- IS FOR THE
PROFESSOR ALSO- IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE JUST OF
THIS- THE USE OF THIS
TECHNOLOGY. FOR TECHNOLOGY'S-
IS TO PUT A LOT OF DATA. IN THE
CLOUD AND SO THAT YOU KNOW THE
DATA COULD BE SHARED AMONGST-
VARIOUS- ENTITIES- WHETHER IT'S
CONSTRUCTION- INFORMATION OR OR
OR OTHER INSIDE INFORMATION OR
OTHERWISE. SO IT IS NOT THE
IDEA ESSENTIALLY BY PUTTING THE
INFORMATION IN THE CLOSET YOU
KNOW DATA COULD BE SURE AMOUNTS
TO. DIFFERENT THEIR
STAKEHOLDERS. ABSOLUTELY AND IT
ALLOWS FOR THERE TO BE. A
RUNNING TIME INVOLVEMENT. OF
AND I WILL REDUCE THIS DOWN
REALLY SMALL. TO THE LEVEL THAT
I WOULD OPERATE AS HI I'M A
GENERAL CONTRACTOR. SO ON SITE-
WE CALL IT RED LINING PLANS
TEAM SO IF SOMETHING JUST
DIDN'T QUITE LINE UP. I WOULD
HAVE TO REDLINE IT DIDN'T TAKE
IT IN. GET IT APPROVED WHILE
THAT'S HAPPENING IN SOME CASES
THE PROJECT COMES TO A COMPLETE
STOP. UNTIL WE GET THAT
APPROVED INSPECTED AND THEN WE
COME BACK OUT AND IMPLEMENT THE
CHANGES. IN THIS PARTICULAR
CASE- WORK COULD BE DONE. ON
SITE. RIGHT WHEN IT'S
HAPPENING. AND AN ENGAGEMENT
INTERACTION COULD BE TAKING
PLACE. ALL BECAUSE OF THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT WE HAVE TODAY
THAT'S MADE AVAILABLE TO US. TO
BE ABLE TO ALLOW PEOPLE FROM
DIFFERENT. SPOTS GEOGRAPHICALLY
TO BE ABLE TO WORK IN ONCE ONE
AREA OF EXPERTISE SO YEAH JUST
A FOLLOW UP ALSO IF THE DATE IS
CAN WE SHARE AMONGST. DIFFERENT
STAKEHOLDERS. ARE THERE ANY
MECHANISMS IN PLACE THAT WOULD
PROTECT THE DATA FROM BEING
LET'S SAY BRIDGE STORE OR
LEAKED OR- OR SHARE THE- YOU
KNOW WITH THE- OTHER PEOPLE.
THAT DON'T KNOW THAT THAT ARE
NOT SUPPOSED TO HAVE A DATA. I
APPRECIATE THAT I WOULD- TURN
TO THE WITNESS FOR THAT SEVEN
BILLION IF WE DON'T HAVE IT-
THEN WE CAN GET THAT ANSWER TO
MAKE. AND I PRE THAT CAN. BUT
BATTLE MONEY CAN I AM TO ALSO.
EXISTING OF THE DATA IF YOU
MARC THAT I AND WILL HAVE YOU
CAN POLICY. I SORRY PROVIDE YOU
WERE- THAT YOU STARTED EXPLAIN
NINE THAT HE- DATA THE BETTER
THAT THIS IS A DO THAT THE GUY
PROVISIONS COULD ALL BE
INTEGRATED AT DATA SECURITY
THEN PUT PART. OF ANY CLOUD
BUSINESS. MARKET SO. ALL THE
EXISTING TECHNIQUES PLOY THE
SITUATION ALSO. THANK YOU
PREFER. ADDITIONAL QUESTION MR
YOU SAY IT A FELLOW CON RETIRED
COURSE HE GOT OUT OF THIS IS
GONNA SPEED UP PROJECTS IS
GOING TO SAVE THE TAX PAYERS
MONIES INTO FOR BIGGER FOR
PROJECTS TO WHOLEHEARTEDLY
SUPPORT THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
FORWARD. THANK THANK YOU ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS FOR MEMBERS
SEEING NONE THE BILL WAS MOVED
BY MR ARAFAT'S SECOND BY MISS
PETRI NORRIS- MISTER GRAYSON DO
WISH TO PROVIDE A CLOSING
STATEMENT YES THANK YOU MR VICE
CHAIR AND THANK YOU COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
AND QUESTIONS AND BROUGHT UP
CONCERNS- WE WILL ADDRESS THOSE
AND FOLLOW UP WITH YOUR OFFICES
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MICHAEL.
THANK YOU. THE MOTION ON AB TEN
THREE SEVEN IS DUE PASSED WITH
AMENDMENTS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ADAM SEVEN AB ONE OH
THREE SEVEN THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS VICE CHAIR
CUNNINGHAM. FASTER CUNNINGHAM I
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HER BREATH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAD HI SEVEN
MEMBER CHAO HI ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS. S. R. PETER
NORRIS ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS
SHELLING AROUND US I MEMBER
SPENT. SO EVERY SEMESTER HI.
VOTERS SIX ZERO AB TEN THIRTY
SEVEN IS OUT CONGRATULATIONS I
SEE MISTER SALAS PRESENT
PROBLEM ONE THAT IS ITEM ONE
WILL GO BACK AND FILE ORDER TO
ITEM ONE AB ONE OH SIX TODAY
WE'RE HEARING AB ONE OH SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS RELATING
TO THE REGION'S RISE GRANT
PROGRAM. BEFORE THE AUTHOR
BEGINS HIS PRESENTATION- WE
GIVE EVERYONE ON NOTICE OF THE
LET ME GIVE EVERYONE NOTICE
AGAIN THAT THE PHONE LINES ARE
NOW OPEN FOR WITNESSES TO GET
IN THE QUEUE THE NUMBER IS
877-692-8957 THE ACCESS CODE IS
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN. ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS
UNDERSTAND OF ACCEPTING
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS IDENTIFIED
IN COMMENTS SIX OF THE BILL
ANALYSIS. CORRECT THANK YOU SIR
AND WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL
DROP THOSE AMENDMENTS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SALAS YOU MAY BEGIN.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS A-
JUST RESTATE I'D LIKE TO TAKE
THAT COMMITTEE SUGGEST
AMENDMENTS WHITE WOULD LIKE
THINK TWENTY FOR ALL THE WORK
ON THIS BILL AB ONE OH SIX
ESTABLISHES THE REGION'S RISE
GRANT PROGRAM WITHIN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. OF PLANNING
AND RESEARCH WHICH WILL ENABLE
REGENTS COLLABORATED CREATE
INCLUSIVE REGIONAL STRATEGIES
FOR ECONOMIC PROSPERITY- NOT
ONLY WILL AB ONE OH SIX HELP
REVITALIZE ECONOMIES WILL ALSO
MAKE THOSE KIND OF THESE MORE
INCLUSIVE AND MORE EQUITABLE
WE'RE ALL IN THIS TOGETHER AND
CALIFORNIA RISES WHEN WE LIFT
UP ALL COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY HAVE MICHAEL WEINBERG
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA FOR
ACTION FUND OF THE SPONSOR OF
THE BILL AND I ALSO HAVE
NICHOLAS ORTIZ PRESIDENT AND
CEO OF THE GREATER BAKERSFIELD
CHAMBER. THANK YOU MR MODERATOR
UNDERSTAND WE ARE MISTER
MICHAEL WEINBERG ON CONFERENCE
LINE. YEAH MR WEINBERG YOU MAY
BEGIN. THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH- BUT YOU'RE CUNNINGHAM A
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU TONY SIMONS FOR YOUR
TYPICAL INCREDIBLY THOROUGH
ANALYSIS OF THE BILL AND YOU'RE
ACTUALLY MEMONS THANK YOU OF
COURSE ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUDY
SALAS FOR OFFERING THIS BILL
RICHARD YOUR DEEP COMMITMENT TO
CREATING COMMUNITY THE MORE
EQUITABLE AND VIBRANT. OUR FIND
THAT THE OCALA FORWARD A
MOVEMENT TO MAKE CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY AND GOVERNMENT WORK FOR
EVERYONE. WE SERVE AS THE
BACKBONE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STEWARDSHIP NETWORK A GROUP OF
OVER THIRTY ORGANIZATIONS
COMMITTED TO EQUITABLE
SUSTAINABLE GROWTH IN ALL THE
STATES REGIONS. I COME BEFORE
YOU TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
NETWORK OF ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATIONS A COMMUNITY
FOUNDATIONS AS WELL AS WELL AS
MANY OTHER SUPPORTERS. AFTER I
PUT ON EIGHTY ONE OBJECTTHE
REGION'S RIGHTS GRANT PROGRAM.
ADMINISTERED BY THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH. IT
DOESN'T BECOME A CLICHE TO SAY
THAT WE DO NOT HAVE AN ECONOMY
THAT WORKS FOR EVERYONE AND
THAT THE PANDEMIC OF AGGRAVATED
RACIAL AND GEOGRAPHIC ECONOMIC
DISPARITIES IN THE STATE. BUT
WHAT DO WE DO ABOUT THIS TO
REBUILD MORE EQUITABLY IN THE
WAKE OF THE PANDEMIC. STABLE
POLICY AT THE ROLE TO PLAY
CERTAINLY AND THE LEGISLATURE
TAKING CRITICAL STEPS INCLUDING
PROVIDING RENTAL RELIEF AND A
HOST OF OTHER MEASURES DESIGNED
TO ASSIST PEOPLE WHO ARE
STRUGGLING. FOR MOVING UP
TOWARDS A MORE EQUITABLE STATE
AND LOCAL ECONOMIC DEVELOPERS
AND SMALL BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
CENTERS WORK INCREDIBLY HARD ON
BEHALF OF THEIR COMMUNITIES AND
THEIR CLIENTS. HELP THEM
WEATHER THE STORM. WHAT IS
NEEDED IS A VITAL COMPLEMENT TO
DEDUCT BIRDS ARE STRATEGIES FOR
INCLUSIVE COMMUNITY AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. THAT ARE
GENERATED AT THE LEVEL OF OUR
STATE THANK THE CONDOM MEANS
WHICH IS TO SAY OUR REGION'S.
ECONOMIC INVESTMENT IN REFORM
STRATEGIES. NEED TO NOT ONLY
AIMS TO GENERATE MORE RACIAL
AND SOCIAL EQUITY THEY NEED TO
BE PUT TOGETHER IN A
FUNDAMENTALLY MORE INCLUSIVE
MATTER. DID A LOT OF DETAIL IN
THE BILL THE ONE KEY COMPONENT
IS THE PARTNERS AT THE REGIONAL
COLLECTIVE THAT WOULD BE FUNDED
BY THESE GRANTS. ARE REQUIRED
TO INCLUDE REPRESENTATIVES OF
THE REGION'S DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES- AND THEY ALSO
INCLUDE KEY INDUSTRY CITY AND
COUNTY GOVERNMENT. LOCAL
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
ORGANIZATIONS AND PRACTITIONERS
COUNCIL GOVERNMENTS BUSINESSES.
EDUCATIONAL AND WORKFORCE
PARTNERS AND LABOR AND
NONPROFIT IN BOTH DROPPED BILL
DROPPING BURKE INNOVATIONS.
I'VE BEEN IN A LOT OF THE TABLE
AND LET ME TELL YOU HOW TRULY
INSPIRING THIS WORK IS. THE
SPECIAL IN A TIME OF POLITICAL
POLARIZATION AND DIVISION. ARE
THERE ARE GOOD EXAMPLES OF THE
KIND OF PROJECT THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. INCLUDING THE BETTER
BAKERSFIELD AND FOUND THE
CURRENT PROJECT. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SALVADORAN DISTRICT.
YOU'RE GONNA HEAR AND JUST A
MINUTE FROM THE CORKIES. THE
PRESIDENT CEO OF THE
BAKERSFIELD CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WILL TELL YOU MORE ABOUT THAT
EFFORT AND IT'S IMPORTANT. BUT
THE GENERATION TO BE STRATEGIES
BIZRATE MISTER WEINBERG. NEED
PLEASE WRAP UP. AFTER THE IN
OUR- REGIONS OUR TO OUR ONE OFF.
THE PRIMARILY BY PRIVATE
PHILANTHROPY. AND INADEQUATELY
CAN THE- AND PRIVATE PAUL
OUTCOMES THAT WOULD MAKE CHANGE.
WE COULD DO BETTER IN A ONE OH
SIX THE BEER. THANK YOU SIR AND
WE ALSO MISSED NICHOLAS. ONLINE
MISTER. YOU MAY BEGIN. THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING BY HERE
CUNNINGHAM AND MEMBERS NAME IS
NICK ORTIZ I AM THE PRESIDENT
OF THE GREATER BAKERSFIELD
CHAMBER AND A PARTNER IN THE
BETTER BAKERSFIELD AND BALANCE
CURRENT INITIATIVE OTHERWISE
KNOWN AS B. THREE K. WE ARE
ALSO HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB ONE AT SIX AND WANT TO THANK
OUR LOCAL ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUDY
SALAS FOR HIS WORK ON THE
SPELL. WERE PART OF THE BROAD
COALITION OF LOCAL REGIONAL AND
STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION
SUPPORTING AB ONE AT SIX
BECAUSE WE KNOW FIRST HAND THE
VALUE OF AN ALL HANDS APPROACH
TO REGIONAL ECONOMIC CHALLENGES
AND A CRITICAL NEED FOR
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT THOSE
EFFORTS HEY YOU KNOW THE BILL
WOULD CREATE A STATE GRANT
PROGRAM THAT MEETS AN IMPORTANT
DEMAND COURAGE IN REGIONS IN
DOING THE WORK OF REIMAGINING
THEIR LOCAL ECONOMIES ENSURING
EVERYONE SHARED IN PROSPERITY.
PETER KAY IS THE TYPE OF
INITIATIVE THAT WOULD BE
SUPPORTED UNDER AB ONE OF SIX
IN KERN OUR ECONOMY LONG
RELIANT ON OIL AND AGRICULTURE
PRODUCTION BASIS CONTINUED
HEADWINDS FROM MARKET AND
REGULATORY PRESSURES ENSURING
THAT OUR REGION NOT ONLY
DIVERSIFY ITS- WAY TO BUILD OUR
STRENGTH BUT THE RELENTLESS
FOCUS ON GOOD QUALITY JOBS THE
PARAMOUNT. THAT FORTY THREE K.
COMES ARE EFFORT BRINGS
TOGETHER STAKEHOLDERS FROM THE
GOVERNMENT PRIVATE SECTOR
POINTER P. EDUCATION LABOR AND
GRASSROOTS COMMUNITY GROUPS
STAKEHOLDERS RECOGNIZE THAT THE
FUTURE OF OUR REGION IS
EVERYONE'S RESPONSIBILITY. THIS
MONTH MARKING AN IMPORTANT
MILESTONE WE REALLY TO BE
CRICKET MARKET ASSESSMENT
REVIEWED ECONOMIC DATA AND
REGIONAL PERFORMANCE THE MARKET
IS SEGMENTED CLEARLY IDENTIFIED
THAT THE EQUITY GAPS IN OUR
REGION ARE A DRAG ON THE
OVERALL ECONOMY ENSURING THAT
EVERY PERSON IN KERN COUNTY HAS
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR PROSPERITY
IS IT JUST THE RIGHT THING TO
DO. IT'S DEMONSTRABLY GOOD FOR
THE ECONOMY ONE OF OUR BEST
PRACTICES ALL DATA FINDINGS AND
STRATEGIES WILL BE UTILIZED
ACROSS THE REGION OUR COUNTY
AND THE CITY OF BAKERSFIELD BUT
YOU'D BE THREE K. AS A
FOUNDATION TO BUILD THEIR
FORMAL ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
STRATEGIES. THAT ENSURE IT'S AN
ONLINE APPROACH AS WE MOVE
FORWARD IN CONCLUSION THESE
EFFORTS TAKE A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF RESOURCES FOR B.
THREE K. WE WERE VERY FORTUNATE
AT THE- THROUGH A GRANT FOR.
THE LABOR WORKFORCE. AID
WITHOUT THAT THE- WE EVEN. TO
GET PEOPLE K. OFF THE GROUND.
MORE REGION'S DESERVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PLAY A BETTER
BRIGHTER. FOR THEIR- I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME TODAY AND
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT
AB ONE OF SIX AND HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
YES SIR PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. NAME ORGANIZATION
AND SUPPORT PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING- DAVID NELSON DIRECTOR
OF POLICY FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASIAN PACIFIC CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND- WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS LEGISLATION THANK
YOU MISTER NELSON. SEEING NO
ONE ELSE SERGEANTS ARE AND IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT SAYING NO ONE
MISTER MODERATOR IS OR ANYONE
ELSE ON THE CONFERENCE LINE.
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU TO STATE A POSITION
OF SUPPORT FOR AB ONE OH SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
ON YOUR PHONE. THAT'S ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME PLEASE.
FOR THE FIRST TEN NINE EIGHTEEN
ONE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MEMBERS
THAT JOINING US ON BEHALF OF
THE INLAND EMPIRE COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT. WAHCONAH
CLIMBED FORTY NINE FOUR NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE MONEY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRAVELS AS THE ENGINE AND
SUPPORT. NINE FIFTY TWO FIVE
TWO. I'M NOT ABOUT EITHER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA X.
COALITION IN SUPPORT. OUR FINAL
LINING CUES LINE THIRTY THREE
THREE THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WHAT'S YOUR NUMBER THAT THE
COMMITTEE PRETTY FANTASY WITH
GARY BUSINESS COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT. NO FURTHER LINES IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
NOW IT'S TIME TO HEAR FROM THE
OPPOSITION IS ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM HERE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. SEEING
NO ONE SERGEANT IS THERE ANYONE
AT THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATIONS SPEAKING OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO ONE MISTER MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ELSE ON THE
CONFERENCE LINE THAT WHICH IS
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. LIKE
THIS STATE A POSITION OF
OPPOSITION TO AB ONE OH SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. IN
THAT OPPOSITION TO ONE OH SIX
MANY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE. THERE ARE NO
LINES IN Q. THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR IT'S NOW TIME FOR
DISCUSSION TO ANY MEMBERS WISH
TO ASK QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR.
SEEING NO ONE THIS OKAY THE
SPEECH NORTH KO WELL THANK YOU
TO THE AUTHOR AND- I THINK WE
ALL RECOGNIZE THE PROFOUND
CHALLENGES FACING THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW- AS WE
ELECTED TO REBUILD- AND TO
SEPARATE THE ECONOMY ON A PATH
TO RECOVERY. BOB AND TO ADDRESS
THE FUNDAMENTAL INCOME
INEQUALITY THAT HAS BOTH BEEN
HIGHLIGHTED AND EXACERBATED BY
THIS CRISIS I THINK AS WE ALL
KNOW THERE'S BEEN A WIDE
VARIETY OF PROPOSALS TO TRY TO.
GET AT THAT ISSUE AND- I JUST
WANT TO EXPRESS MY THANKS TO
YOU BECAUSE THIS TO ME IS A
PROPOSAL THAT AT LOOKS TO CHECK
GROW THE PIE TED LIFT UP
COMMUNITIES AND TO. ADD TO
DELIVER SHARED PROSPERITY FOR
OUR STATE SO I'M REALLY
APPRECIATE S. AND WOULD LOVE TO
BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR. I'D
LOVE TO HAVE YOU AS A CAUGHT
THANK YOU. WHAT SINGLE OTHER
QUESTIONS THIS BILL WAS MOVED
BY MR RAMEAU'S SECONDED BY MR
CHOW- THE MOTION ON AB ONE OF
SIX IS DUE PASSED WITH
AMENDMENTS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. I AM ONE AB ONE OH SIX
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS. BY
STRENGTHENING HAM. BUSTER
CUNNINGHAM HIGH. HI
BOERNER HORVATH. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHAD BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHAO HI SO WE WERE
PETRIE-NORRIS. SYRUPY TREE
NORRIS BY SELLING OVER RAMOS.
THE I SAW REMEMBER. SEVEN
RESPECT HI SOME OF THE RIVER
HARBOR FULLER BURNER HARPER
ABOUT HI. THANK YOU GUYS I
APOLOGIZE I DIDN'T GIVE A
CHANCE TO CLOSE BUT THE GOOD
NEWS IS. BILLS OUT. SIX ZERO.
ALL RIGHT. NOW WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO. FILE ITEM EIGHT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA. TODAY
WE'RE HEARING AB SIX TO EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA
RELATING TO BREAKING BARRIERS
FOR EMPLOYMENT OR TO IMPLEMENT
SKEWS ME BEFORE THE AUTHOR
BEGINS HIS PRESENTATION IT'S
TIME TO EVERYONE KNOWS THE
PHONE LINES ARE NOW OPEN FOR
WITNESSES TO GETTING Q. THE
CALL IN NUMBER AGAIN IS
877-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
THREE SEVEN. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA I UNDERSTAND TO BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS IDENTIFIED IN COMMON
SIX OF THE BILL ANALYSIS THAT'S
CORRECT MR THANK YOU SIR-
MISTER MODERATOR ACTUALLY THOSE
AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED WITHOUT
OBJECTION YOU MAY BEGIN WHEN
READY. THANK YOU I'LL BE BRIEF
AB SIX TO A WATER LINE THE-
STATE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
PLAN WHILE EXPANDING RENEWING
THE INITIATIVE BY ASSISTING
INDIVIDUALS. IN OBTAINING THE
FUNDAMENTAL PROGRAM TO SUPPORT
SERVICES NECESSARY TO SECURE
MEANINGFUL AND STABLE CAREERS.
THE AVERAGE MULTIPLE SERVICES
TO MEET WORKERS INDIVIDUAL
NEEDS AND REACH PEOPLE WHO FACE
SYSTEMIC BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT. OUT WITH US SO WE
HAVE TO WITNESSES BOB LANTER
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
ASSOCIATION CURRENT EARL. D.
JESSE CENTER DOMESTIC ABUSE
TREATMENT CENTER. THANK YOU SIR
MISTER MODERATOR UNDERSTAND WE
HAVE MISTER LANTER ON THE LINE.
YES CAN YOU HEAR ME YEAH YOU
MAY BEGIN. GREAT THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS BOB
LANTER EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
ASSOCIATION. AND I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK ASSEMBLY MAN GARCIA
FOREST ON SUPPORT OF THIS
EFFORT OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS AND I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE
THOROUGH REVIEW IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN THE STATE LEGISLATURE
PASSED THE BREAKING BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT INITIATIVES
SPECIFICALLY TO IMPROVE ACCESS.
TO THE INVESTMENTS THAT THE
STATE HAS MADE IN CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION IMPORTANT
REALITY IS THERE ARE SIZEABLE
GROUP OF CALIFORNIANS UNABLE TO
ACCESS THOSE INVESTMENTS AND WE
ARE IN DANGER OF LEAVING BEHIND
COMMUNITIES AND INDIVIDUALS WHO
HISTORICALLY DISENFRANCHISED
WHO HAVE BEEN HISTORICALLY
DISENFRANCHISED AND PRECLUDED
FROM OPPORTUNITY AND CAREER
PATHWAYS. IN THE LEGISLATURE
FUNDED BREAKING BARRIERS IT WAS
CLEAR THAT THE NEED WAS
EXTENSION AND URGENT TEN POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS WAS
RELEASED UPON TWENTY THREE
PROPOSALS PUBLISHED RECEIVED
OVER HOW AND THIRTY APLIK. EVEN
KOBE DID NEED TO FOR EFFORT FOR
DOCTOR AND SIR WAS OBVIOUS
WE'RE ALL WORKING TO ENSURE
THOSE LEFT BEHIND. COULD NOT
FALL FURTHER BACK. AB SIX
TWENTY EIGHT THE DESIGNS AND ON
THE- IN THE- OF THE BREAKING
BARRIERS PROGRAM. BOTH THE
GEOGRAPHY AND PROGRAM
PARTICIPANTS IN STREAMLINED THE
APPLICATION PROCESS AND ALLOWS
FOR MORE FLEXIBILITY IN HOW
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION
CAN APPLY. THESE LOCAL
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE THE CULTURAL
COMPETENCIES AND A DEDICATED
HISTORY WORKING WITH
INDIVIDUALS WITH BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT. ACCORDING TO THE
PUBLIC POLICY INSTITUTE OF
CALIFORNIA ABOUT FOUR IN TEN
CALIFORNIANS ARE STILL LIVING
IN OR NEAR POVERTY. AND 78% OF
THOSE ARE WORKING IN FAMILIES
WITH AT LEAST. ARE WE ARE IN
FAMILIES WITH AT LEAST ONE
WORKING ADULT THE MAJORITY
WORKING FULL TIME AND THAT IS
UNACCEPTABLE. EIGHTY SIX TWENTY
EIGHT THE DESIGNED TO COMBAT
THAT AND IS A CRITICAL TOOL TO
OUR STATE. PROVIDING PATHWAYS
TO FAMILY SUSTAINING WAGES AND
QUALITY JOBS AND NOW MORE THAN
EVER IS NEEDED TO IMPROVE
ACCESS TO OPPORTUNITIES. FOR
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE BEEN DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED BY THE CO THE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC WE RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR AND I ABOUT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR I UNDERSTAND WE
HAVE MS RURAL THE CONFERENCE
SPEAKING. YES I'M HERE SIR YOU
MAY BEGIN. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU CHAIR THANK
YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA THANK
YOU COMMITTEE MEMBERS PERFECT
CENTERING THIS IMPORTING
LEGISLATION MY NAME IS KAREN
EARL I AM THE C. E. O. OF
GENESIS CENTER A NONPROFIT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE INTERVENTION
AND PREVENTION ORGANIZATION
THAT PROVIDES TRAUMA INFORMED.
CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE SERVICES
TO SURVIVORS IMPACTED BY
DOMESTIC AND SEXUAL VIOLENCE
TODAY I AM HERE IN MY CAPACITY
AS KOHLI OF THE CULTURALLY
RESPONSIVE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
NETWORK A STATE WIDE COALITION
OF SIXTEEN DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT PROVIDE
SERVICES FOR SURVIVORS AND
FAMILIES SENSITIVE TO THE NEEDS
AND EXPERIENCES OF DIVERSE
LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND CULTURES
WHILE APPROACHES TO SUPPORTING
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE INTERVENTION
SHOULD MEET THE CULTURAL NEED
TO SPECIFIC COMMUNITIES.
INDIGENOUS BLACK LATIN ACT
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
IMMIGRANT OR HEARING IMPAIRED
ALL OF WHICH ARE SERVED BY
LOCAL AGENCIES AND OUR NETWORK
THERE IS A UNIVERSAL SOLUTION
THAT HELPS SURVIVORS REBUILD
THEIR LIVES ECONOMIC SECURITY
IN CALIFORNIA THE MATH BIG
VIOLENT IMPACT IN FOUR
HOUSEHOLDS WITH AN INCOME OF
SIXTY THOUSAND DOLLARS OR LESS.
THE CDC HAS DOCUMENTED THAT
EVEN A SMALL INCREASE IN FAMILY
INCOME IS LINKED TO A DECREASED
AND FAMILY VIOLENCE EARLIER
THIS YEAR THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION RECOMMENDING THAT TO
SUPPORT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SURVIVORS AND THEIR FAMILIES
THE STATE SHOULD NASA SHOULD
TAKE NECESSARY STEPS TO PROVIDE
JOB. SKILLS TRAINING AND WORK
FOR SUPPORT TO SURVIVORS. AB
SIX TWENTY EIGHT WITH STAR ON
THIS PATH. IT WOULD PRIOR
SURVIVORS AND IT TAKES THE
WHOLE FAMILY AND WHOLE
COMMUNITY APPROACH SEEING THE
LONG VIEW WHERE WE NEED TO
RECOGNIZE THOSE AT RISK OF
PERPETRATING VIOLENCE AND
ADDRESS THE ECONOMIC STRESS
THAT CAN OFTEN BE A
CONTRIBUTING FACTOR WITH THE
GOAL OF PREVENTING VIOLENCE
BEFORE IT HAPPENS. THE C. R. D.
V. AND MISSOURI PLEASE WRAP UP.
WE ARE PROUD TO SUPPORT SB SIX
TWENTY EIGHT AS PART OF
BUILDING A FUTURE WHERE ALL
CALIFORNIANS CAN RECOVER FROM
TRAUMA AND THRIVE ON THEIR OWN
TERMS THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LET
ME ASK IF THERE'S ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM HERE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. SEEING NO
ONE SERGEANTS IS THERE ANYONE
AT THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
SEEING NO ONE- MISTER MODERATOR
IS ANYONE ELSE ON THE
CONFERENCE LINE HERE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU COULD
LIKE STATE SUPPORT FOR A BI SIX
TWENTY NGUYEN PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AGAIN SUPPORT FOR A
BI. SIX TWENTY EIGHT PRESS ONE
BUTTON ZERO AT THIS TIME. LOCAL
FIRST ONLINE FORTY SEVEN OR
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MR VICE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHO SHALL GO
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA MARKET
CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NEXT WE HAVE LINE THIRTY
FOUR THREE FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. A GOOD AFTERNOON- AIRPORT
TO OFFER LIKE TO BE A LIVE
AMONG THE PUBLIC AWARE
COSPONSORED IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB SIXTY WAY BACK THREE TOP.
NEXT TO MY FIFTY FOUR FIVE FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
SIR NUMBERS PRIVILEGE ON BEHALF
OF CENTER FOR EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES IN THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANKS
LEVINE FIFTY SIX FIVE SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
ALEX KESSLER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP TO END
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN SUPPORT.
I'M NOT ABOUT EITHER ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA EDGE
COALITION IN SUPPORT. NINE
FIFTY THREE FIVE THREE. I WOULD
MARINO FROM THE EDUCATIONAL
LEADERSHIP FOUNDATION IN FRESNO
IS SUPPORT. ON OUR FINAL LINE
IN QS. FIVE EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT.
MR PRAYER GOOD MORNING-
HONORABLE CHECK NUMBERS MY NAME
IS JESSICA KING DATA- EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CENTER CHILD
ALONE BEACH COMMUNITY HISPANIC
ASSOCIATION- WE PROVIDE OUR
REENTRY SERVICES AND WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB SIX TO
EIGHT. THANK YOU FOR THE LINE
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU MR MODERATOR IT'S TIME NOW
TO HEAR FROM THE OPPOSITION IS
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM HERE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. SEEING
KNOWN AS OR ANYONE AT THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NO ONE
MISTER MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE CONFERENCE LINE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. YOU DIDN'T
SHARE POSITION OF OPPOSITION TO
AB SIX TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. BUT
AGAIN THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO IF YOU ARE ALREADY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB. SIX TO EIGHT.
THANK YOU TURN ON LINES INTO AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU IT'S NOW
TIME FOR MEMBER DISCUSSION DOES
ANYONE WISH TO ASK QUESTIONS.
SEEING NO ONE THERE WAS- DO YOU
WISH TO CLOSER. RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL THANK YOU. THE BILL
THE MOTION ON A V. SIX TO EIGHT
IS DUE PASSED WITH AMENDMENTS
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS IT WAS MOVED BY
MR RAMA SECOND BY MS
BOERNER HORVATH- PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. I DON'T EIGHT AB SIX
TO EIGHT. BUSTER CUNNINGHAM I
THANK YOUR CUNNINGHAM AYE PART
MADE THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED-
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BARNHART QUORUM.
SEPTEMBER BOERNER HORVATH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAD CELEBRITY
SHALL I SOME OF OUR
PETRIE-NORRIS SERVER
PETRIE-NORRIS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMOS SOME OF A RAMOS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SPENT. SO IN THAT
RESPECT I. THE VOTERS SIX ZERO
AB SIX TWO EIGHT IS OUT
CONGRATULATIONS I HAVE TO RUN
PRESENT ANOTHER COMMITTEE SO I
THINK WE'LL PASSED THE GAP.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO THAT WORK
THANK YOU SENATE YOUR CHAIR AND
HELPS MAKE IT MORE TRANSPARENT
WITH THAT. THE. BUT. WELL YEAH
YEAH. YEAH. AND WE DON'T ALL
AGREE MORE OKAY I DON'T
REMEMBER THE LAST. YEAH A ONE.
PEOPLE OFTEN SECOND. I DON'T
KNOW IF THAT THAT WHAT.
PROBABLY ONE OF THE THINGS THAT.
AFTER THE MEETING- I THINK THE
PROBLEM.
OKAY HAVE A GOOD ONE
WELL ACTUALLY. IT IS MEASURES
YEAH. OKAY- LET'S SAY A THAT
BRINGS US TO THE NEXT BILL AND
LET'S- DO- ITEM TWELVE A. B.
ELEVEN OH SIX- THAT'S- WOULD
YOU BE. READY TO PROCEED. N. A.
B. ELEVEN OH SIX IS BY CHAIR
CERVANTES- RELATING TO THE
TRAINING AND EMPLOYMENT DUE TO
ILLNESS THE CHAIR HAS ASKED
THAT A MISS UP ON HOW OF IT TO
PRESENT THE BILL NOW BEFORE SHE
PRESENTS THE BILL LET ME GIVE
EVERYBODY NOTICED THAT THE
PHONE LINES ARE NOW OPEN FOR
WITNESSES TO GET IN THE QUEUE.
THE CALL IN NUMBER AGAIN IS
877-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR THREE SEVEN. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OF ONE HUNDRED I
UNDERSTAND YOUR YOU WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMUNITY
AMENDMENTS IDENTIFY. IN COMMON
SIX OF THE BILL ANALYSIS. AND
IS THAT CORRECT THAT IS CORRECT
OKAY VERY GOOD MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL ADOPT THOSE
AMENDMENTS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU
MAY BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY YES
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS- THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE IN THE MEN'S LISTED
IN COMMON SIX OF THE ANALYSIS
AB ELEVEN OH SIX ESTABLISHES
THE PILOT PROJECT TO SUPPORT
THE ENHANCEMENT. OF A REGIONAL
TRAINING CENTER NETWORK WHICH
CAN WORK HAND IN HAND WITH
BUSINESS OWNERS SMALL BUSINESS
SERVICE PROVIDERS AND OTHER
WORKFORCE PARTNERS TO GET
PEOPLE BACK TO WORK. OVER
TWENTY ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION
UNEMPLOYED UP OVER TWENTY ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION
UNEMPLOYMENT ASSISTING CLAIMS
HAVE BEEN FILED IN CALIFORNIA
BETWEEN MARCH FOURTEENTH AND
APRIL TENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
MANY OF THE INDUSTRY SECTORS
MOST IMPACTED DURING THE
PANDEMIC ARE NOT EXPECTED TO
RETURN TO PRE PANDEMIC LEVELS
OF ECONOMIC ACTIVITY FOR
SEVERAL YEARS INCLUDING
BUSINESSES IN THE HOSPITALITY
ACCOMMODATION AND TOURISM
SECTORS. EVEN IN THOSE
INDUSTRIES SECTORS THAT ARE
ANTICIPATED TO RECOVER MORE
QUICKLY. MANY LOWER SKILLED
JOBS WILL PERMANENTLY BE
REPLACED OR SIGNIFICANTLY
MODIFIED THROUGH AUTOMATION E.
COMMERCE BUSINESS MODELS. A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO EXPERIENCE
NEGATIVE ECONOMIC IMPACTS TO
THE PANDEMIC. ARE WOMEN AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR WITH LIMITED
ACCESS TO EDUCATION AND
TRAINING BEYOND HIGH SCHOOL. AB
ELEVEN OH SIX LEVERAGES
EXISTING PROGRAMS AND EXPERTISE
TO RESPOND TO THESE COVERT
NINETEEN UNEMPLOYMENT
CHALLENGES. QUICKLY AND HELP
PEOPLE GET BACK TO WORK WITH ME
TO THEIR NUMBER OF WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. INCLUDING DR HERB
CALLAHAN FROM THE GILL
CORPORATION AND LAME LARRY
ABERNATHY RETIRED VICE
PRESIDENT DV TREE SURGERY
UTILITY ARBORIST ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF DOCTOR
CALLAHAN ARE YOU ON THE LINE.
MR ALL OPERATOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE CHECK TO SEE A DOCTOR
CALLAHAN IS ON THE LINE.
BECAUSE I WAS WAITING AT THE
TOP OF MY PHONE ON HOLD. HI
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHAU MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME A COUPLE MINUTES TO
TALK ABOUT HOW IMPORTANT
PASSING OF. ASSEMBLY BILL OF
THOSE SIX WILL BE TO MY
ORGANIZATION THE GILL
CORPORATION. COMMENTED MR
CALLINAN THE CORPORATE VICE
PRESIDENT HUMAN RESOURCES FOR
THE GILL CORPORATION
HEADQUARTERED IN EL MONTE
CALIFORNIA. AEROSPACE
MANUFACTURING COMPANY THAT
MANUFACTURES AND SUPPLIES
AEROSPACE MATERIALS AND PARTS.
USED PRIMARILY THE
MANUFACTURING MAINTENANCE OF
BOTH COMMERCIAL AND MILITARY
AIRCRAFT. BUT I'M RELATIVELY
NEW TO THE GILL CORPORATION
I'VE BEEN HERE SIX MONTHS I WAS
DOWNSIZED TO COPE WITH MY
PREVIOUS ORGANIZATION. I'M NEW
TO THE GILL CORPORATION I'M NOT
NEW TO THE IMPORTANCE OF
TRAINING EMPLOYEES AND HELP
THEM. TO HELP RETAIN THEM
ENGAGE THEM AND KEEP THEIR
SKILL SET SHORT. WHAT I
RECOGNIZE IS BACK IN THE EARLY
NINETEEN NINETIES WHEN I WAS
YOUNGER- STRUCTURE. IF I COULD
MAKE BETTER BELIEVE THAT CAN
MAKE A BETTER PULLING COURT SO
I TAKE THAT AS A MANTRA. WELL
IN FACT MAKE BETTER ASSOCIATES
I THINK ABOUT ORGANIZATION MY
PHONE THAT WHEN COMPANIES.
DEDICATE RESOURCES AND
LEADERSHIP TO TRY TO DEVELOP
THEIR EMPLOYEES. MAKE BETTER
EMPLOYEES ON A BETTER
ORGANIZATION. THE GILL
CORPORATION AS LONG PROMOTED
THE DEVELOPMENT OF ITS
EMPLOYEES WHETHER PORTER'S OVER
EL CAMINO COLLEGE OF THE
TRAINING AND SUPPORT PROVIDED
TO THE ATP IS A POST BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL. IN HELPING US
MAKE THOSE BETTER EMPLOYEES. IN
TWENTY TWENTY LIKE MANY OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS. THEY GO
CORPORATION WAS IMPACTED
SIGNIFICANTLY BY KOBE TO THE
ECONOMIC CRISIS WE HAVE TO
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE OUR
WORKFORCE- IN ORDER TO SURVIVE
WE HAVE TO SAY GOODBYE TO A LOT
OF HIGH QUALITY WELL TRAINED
DEDICATED EMPLOYEES. AND OUR EL
MONTE LOCATION WE HAD A LITTLE
MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY OVER FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY
FIVE EMPLOYEES WE TOOK CARE OF
THEM WAS SEVERANCE EXTENDED
BENEFITS. I TRY TO BRING THEM
BACK AS WE SAW IN A PARTICULAR
VOLUMES. OF THIS REDUCTION OF
COURSE DROVE UP OUR TURNOVER
RATE OR EMPLOYEE TURNOVER
RATES. TO LEVELS WE'VE NEVER
SEEN BEFORE MAKING US IN
ELIGIBLE FOR ETP FUNDED
TRAINING. WE CAN'T WE RUN
AROUND 1670% TURNOVER BUT DUE
TO THE REDUCTION FORCE IN
TWENTY TWENTY OR TURNOVER. FOR
TWENTY TWENTY WAS AT 54% NOW AS
WE SEE THE BUSINESS SLOWLY
START TO RETURN WE FIND
OURSELVES HIRING HIM- THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE LIKE TO A
LOT OF GOOD EMPLOYEES MANY OF
THEM FOUND WORK ELSEWHERE. I
KNOW OUR NEW WORKFORCE IS LESS
SKILLED IN THE TRAINING
PROVIDED THROUGH THE U. T. P.
WILL HELP US ENGAGE THIS NEW
WORKFORCE. HELP US GET THEIR
SKILL SET UP TO WHERE IT NEEDS
TO BE AND HELP US AGAIN BUILD A
BETTER COMPANY BY MAKING BETTER
WELL TRAINED. ENGAGED EMPLOYEES.
REPORTERS IT OKAY TO CALL HIM A
VERY. BUT HERE'S WHAT TRAINING.
AND NO MORE THAN EVER AS WE
REBUILD REBUILD A WORKFORCE. WE
WILL PROVIDE A PARTNERSHIP ONCE
AGAIN CAN LIKELY ONLY DO THAT.
IF AB ELEVEN OH SIX PASSES.
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR TIME-
BUT- IT WOULDN'T. BE HAPPENING
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
ON NEXT WE HAVE MISTER LARRY
OPEN. NINETY WITH- HE'S A
RETIRED VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
ARBORIST ASSOCIATION. ARE YOU
ON THE LINE SIR. THANK YOU. YES
I STARTED MY CAREER IN NINETEEN
SIXTY NINE AND THE WORK FOR THE
DAILY TRIPS PER COMPANY FOR
FORTY NINE YEARS- STARRED AT
THE GROUND PERSON I WORKED ALL
THE WAY UP THE BEEN. VICE
PRESIDENT GENERAL MANAGER WHEN
I RETIRED. I'M CURRENTLY ACTIVE
WITH YOUR- UTILITY ARBORIST
ASSOCIATION AND I ALWAYS AND
HEART AND WHOLEHEARTEDLY
SUPPORT. A. B. ELEVEN OH SIX.
I'VE SEEN FIRSTHAND HOW
STATEWIDE COMMUNITY COMMUNITY-
COLLEGE- CONTRACT EDUCATION
CENTERS. WAS ABLE TO. PROVIDE
SHORT TERM OF COURSE USED TO
NEW WORKERS VERY QUICKLY. AS
YOU RECALL THE IN THE- FALL OF
TWENTY NINETEEN. THERE WAS A-
OF- WORKERS TO PROVIDE UTILITY
LIFEGUARDS WORK- IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND UTILITIES
WERE ASKING FOR LIKE THREE
THOUSAND- WORKERS. ADDITIONAL
WORKERS TO WHAT THEY ALREADY
HAD AND THE ONLY WAY THEY COULD
NOT FULFILL THAT WAS TO BRING
IN SOME OUTSIDE OF STATE
WORKERS. THANKFULLY PG&E
STEPPED UP THEN- PROVIDED SOME
SEED MONEY FOR COLLEGE TO
DEVELOP UTILITY LINE CLEARANCE
UTILITY ARE RESTRAINED PROGRAM.
AND THE UTILITY ARMS SO SHE
ASIAN PROVIDED. I DIDN'T THE
LEADERSHIP AND THAT'S HOW I WAS
DRAWN INTO A THIS PROGRAM- THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY- COLLEGES-
FORM EIGHTY MEMBER INDUSTRY
STEERING COMMITTEE WHICH
INCLUDED PRIMARY- LIFEGUARDS
CONTRACTORS. INDUSTRY NONPROFIT
ASSOCIATIONS INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES THAT MINUTES MORE
UTILITIES THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM IN THE I. D. W. IN IN A
VERY FEW MONTHS- THIS PROGRAM
WAS BUT THE PROGRAM WAS
DEVELOPED- FOR TWO HUNDRED
HOURS OF ON THE JOB ARE ARE
ACTUALLY TWO HUNDRED HOURS OF
TRAINING. OVER FIVE WEEKS. WITH
THE- THE GOAL OF BRINGING TWO
THOUSAND NEW WORKERS INTO OUR
INDUSTRY. I FIFTY YEAR PLUS THE
INVOLVED IN THE INDUSTRY I'VE
NEVER SEEN ANYTHING. LIKE THIS
THIS IS A FIRST FOR OUR
INDUSTRY THE PROGRAM WAS
EXPANDED NOW DOES SEVEN
COLLEGES. THE END VERY SHORT
TIME DURING THE- TRYING TIMES
OF THIS PANDEMIC. WE'VE HAD
OVER NINE THAT A GRADUATION AND
THE MORE TO COME- SO NEARLY-
ALL GRADUATES FROM THE PROGRAM
HAVE BEEN HIRED AND ARE
RECEIVING GOOD WAGES. THEY'RE
OUT THERE REPRESENTED BY THE
IBEW WAGES OF START AT TWENTY
ONE SIXTY THREE AN HOUR WITH
FULL BENEFITS. AND THEY CAN
PROGRESS TO- THIRTY SIX OH FIVE
AN HOUR WITHIN EIGHTEEN MONTHS.
SIR IF I ASK BILL THE PLEASE.
YEAH THE BILL WILL HELP- BRING
MORE AWARENESS THE COLLEGES FOR
A THREE COMPANIES- END UP.
WITHOUT A DOUBT THIS IS THE OF
A BILL THAT'S GOING TO HELP OUR
INDUSTRY AND I THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU SIR
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY SEEN NO ONE
HERE IN THE ROOM WHO WISH TO
SPEAK- LET'S TURN TO OUR REMOTE
SITE I DON'T SEE ANYBODY THERE.
SO WITH THAT- WAS MODERATOR
WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN UP THE
PHONE LINES FOR COLLEGE. IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF. AB
ELEVEN OH SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. CAN ONE
MOMENT BECAUSE BY NUMBERS. AT
FIRST WE HAVE BY NUMBER SIXTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THANK YOU
MY NAME IS WHAT IS ART I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF ECONOMIC
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AT
THE COLLEGE STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THE BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AN EX PLEASE. THANK YOU ONCE
AGAIN LAYS THE GERMAN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
ELEVEN OH SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. I HAVE NO ONE ELSE
THANK YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM MODERATOR
LET'S TURN TO OPPOSITION SEEING
NO ONE HERE IN THE ROOM WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
ALL OR THE HEARING ROOM- ADAMA
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN A PHONE
LINE FOR OPPOSITION PLEASE.
THANK YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB ELEVEN OH SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. THANKS AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND I HAVE NO ONE IN
Q. PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MET MADAM A MODERATOR
LET'S BRING BACK TO COMEY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MISTER SMITH
GO HADN'T PLAYED UP THE
PACKAGES THANKS FOR PRESENTING
THE BILL ON BEHALF OF THE
AUTHOR I WAS GOING TO GIVE YOU.
SOME HUMOR HARD TIME BUT THANK
YOU FOR PRESENTING UP IF
THERE'S NOT A MOTION I'LL GO
AHEAD MAKE A MOTION TO MOVE IT
FORWARD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I'LL SECOND THAT MOTION-
WITH THAT- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. THE- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH UP- MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL- ITEM TWELVE AB.
ONE ONE OH SIX THE MOTION IS A
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. VICE CHAIR
CUNNINGHAM. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATHHI SOME ARE
BOERNER HORVATH I STILL
REMEMBER JAZZ. HI SHEILA MEMBER
CHAD. A SERVER PETRIE-NORRIS AS
A MEMBER RAMOS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SPENT. SOMERS SMITH HI. YOUR
THREE BOTH CELL WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS ON
CALL ON CALL CORRECT. R. EIGHT
AND SEE NOW LET'S MOVE TO THE
NEXT ITEM I BELIEVE IT IS ITEM
TEN AB ELEVEN TEN DOT SO SOME A
MEMBER WITH US. WELCOME WELCOME
TO OUR COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. GOOD TO SEE
EVERYBODY THIS MORNING IT'S
ELEVEN- HOW MUCH I'VE AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO. PRESENTA THIS
LEGISLATION SENATE BILL ONE ONE
ONE ZERO I LIKE TO THINK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR- THE
CONSIDERATION AN EXTENSIVE WORK
ON THE BILL ANALYSIS- YOU KNOW
I. I ACCEPT THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS AND THIS LEGISLATION
WHAT IT DOES IS IT PROPOSES TO
ESTABLISH THE OFFICE OF THE
CALIFORNIA CLEAN FLEET A
SALARIED OR ITS THE- OFFICE
WOULD HAVE THREE PRIMARY
FUNCTIONS FIRST IT. WOULD BE
AVAILABLE TO ASSIST PUBLIC
AGENCIES LIKE SCHOOL- I WAS IN
SCHOOL DISTRICTS SEVEN. I'M
TRYING TO DISTRICTS AND PUBLIC
AGENCIES FROM. FROM SMALL AND
RURAL AREAS OF THE STATE WITH
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IN THE
PROCUREMENT OF ZERO EMISSION
FLEET VEHICLES SECONDED WOULD
HELP REDUCE THE PURCHASE PRICE
OF ZERO EMISSION- FLEETS. BY
STREAMLINING BULK PURCHASE
ORDERS FOR MULTIPLE ENTITIES AT
A TIME OR AS THE AS WE STATED
IN THE ANALYSIS BY BALL
PURCHASE UNDER THE MASTER
SERVICES AGREEMENT AND THIRTY
IT. WOULD VIED ARE PUBLIC
AGENCIES ACROSS THE STATE WITH
WITH ACCESS TO LOW COST
FINANCING. ASTHEY BEGIN TO
TRANSITION TO A ZERO EMISSION
FLEET. NOW THERE ARE- THERE.
ARE CURRENTLY- DOZENS OF STATE
EMPLOYEES TASKED WITH HELPING
TO ADVANCE ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES- HERE IN OUR STATE BUT
THEIR EFFORTS COULD BE MADE
MORE EFFECTIVE AND MORE
EFFICIENT. BY PROVIDING AN
OFFICE WHOSE EXPLICIT MISSION
IS TO INSURE THAT THEY PROVIDE
AND A COORDINATING AND AN
OUTREACH FUNCTION. NOW DO YOU
THERE IS AN URGENT NEED THERE'S
ALWAYS BEEN AN URGENT NEED. TO
HELP CALIFORNIA SMALL AND RURAL
AREAS OF THE STATE IN SOME SOME
SOME JURISDICTIONS. EITHER
PUBLIC AGENCIES WHO LACK
RESOURCES LACK INTERNAL STAFF
SUPPORT. AND DEVELOPING A CLEAR
ROADMAP FOR A DAY ADAPTING TO
SOME TECHNOLOGY AND IN THIS
CASE TRANSITION IN OUR
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR TWO ZERO
AND LOW EMISSION. WILL HELP
STAKEHOLDERS ARE PUBLIC
AGENCIES LARGE AND SMALL IN
URBAN AND RURAL AREAS AVOID
MISSTEPS AND SOME- CONFUSION
THAT'S CALIFORNIA'S WE
CONSIDERED ACTIVELY PURSUE A
TRANSITION TO ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES. WE MUST ENSURE THAT
WE NEED TO DEVELOP THE RIGHT
STRATEGY THAT WE HAVE A CLEAR
ROADMAP THAT WILL SUPPORT THIS
TRANSITION AND IT SHOULD BEGIN
BY ENSURING THAT ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES ARE MADE AVAILABLE TO
ALL JURISDICTIONS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. IT'S A WITH US ON-
BY PHONE TO OFFER SOME
TESTIMONY IS A DAVID WEISS COFF
WITH NEXT GEN POLICY. AND TAKE
THAT TIMOTHY SHANNON WITH THE
TWIN RIVERS UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT THANK YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BILLS MOVED
AND BEFORE WE GO TO A
WITNESSES- LIKE TO REMIND
CALLERS TO CALL IN NUMBER IS
877-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
THREE SEVEN AND MISTER RIVERS
ARE YOU ACCEPTING TO- THE
AMENDMENT SAYS YEAH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NOW LET'S GO TO- TO
WITNESSES STARTING WITH MISTER
DAVID WEISS COFF WEISS COFF
WITH THE NEXT GEN POLICY SENIOR
POLICY ADVISER. ARE YOU ON THE
LINE SIR. YES I AM CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES WE CAN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MR FEATURE COMMITTEE
NUMBERS THANK YOU TO THE BILL'S
AUTHOR SUDDENLY NUMBER RIVAS.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF ESPECIALLY
TWENTY SILENCE FOR A COUPLE
ENGAGEMENT AND ASSISTANCE ON
THIS BILL. HI MY NAME IS DAVID
WHAT'S UP I'M WITH NEXT GEN
CALIFORNIA- WEIRD ORGANIZATION
THAT WORKS FOR PROGRESSIVE
POLICY CHANGE TO ADDRESS.
ENVIRONMENTAL SOCIAL RACIAL AND
ECONOMIC INEQUITIES IN
CALIFORNIA- THIS BILL RESPONSE
TO SHARED MADE BY MANY SMALLER
PUBLIC ENTITIES INCLUDING
SCHOOLS FOR ATTENTION
TRANSISTORISED MARKET
DISPARITIES AND OTHERS.
DIFFERENT IS ALL- OFTEN SEE THE
POTENTIAL COST SAVINGS AND THE
HEALTH BENEFITS THAT COME FROM
ADOPTING ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES. BUT THEY MAY LACK
ACCESS TO THE TYPE OF RESOURCES
AND STAFFING CAPACITY AND LOW
COST CAPITAL FINANCING. THAT
THEY MAY NEED IN ORDER TO
CONFIDENTLY MOVE FORWARD IN THE
STATE MATTER THAT. SOME LARGER
JURISDICTIONS TO. THESE ARE A
COMPUTER TO. THE APPROPRIATE
EQUIPMENT PRETENDING TO.
AVAILABLE TO NICOLAS THE PRICE-
AND THEY MAY NOT HAVE STAFF
AVAILABLE TO PURSUE AVAILABLE
FUNDING AN INCENTIVE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT THE STATE IS
MADE AVAILABLE. THIS BILL
RESPONDS TO THESE NEEDS ARE
PRODUCING KIND OF TOOLS THAT
ARE AVAILABLE TO LARGER CITIES
COUNTY GOVERNMENTS TO THE REST
OF THE STATE'S PUBLIC ENTITIES.
ST PRIMARY COMPONENTS THE BILL
AS MYSTERY THIS HAS SKETCHED
OUT FOR US- IF. IT CREATES
OMBUDSPERSON OFFICE. TO LEAD
OUTREACH TO THESE ENTITIES THAT
CAN BENEFIT FROM THIS TYPE OF
ASSISTANCE AND CONNECT THEM.
BOTH WITH AVAILABLE RESOURCES
AND PEER LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES.
IT ALSO LEVERAGES THE COMBINED
BUYING POWER OF ALL OF THESE
PURCHASES TO TRACK DOWN COST
REDUCTIONS AND CREATE GREATER
CERTAINTY FOR EMERGING MEDIUM
AND HEAVY DUTY. ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE MANUFACTURERS.
ENVIRONMENT IT CREATES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MOBILIZE
SIGNIFICANT PRIVATE CAPITAL
THAT MAY OTHERWISE NOT BE
AVAILABLE WITH THIS WITHOUT
THIS TYPE OF STATEMENT PROCESS-
THIS. URGENT NEED TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE AND HELP THE SMALL
ON HER ACCOUNT AT SCHOOLS
TRANSIT OPERATORS- TO SAVE
MONEY AND GAIN ACCESS TO THE
VEHICLES. FOR THIS REASON I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
NEXT WE HAVE MISTER TIMOTHY
SHANNON WITH THE TWIN RIVERS
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT- WHO IS
THE ALSO THE DIRECTOR OF
TRANSPORTATION. MISTER SHANNON
ARE YOU ON THE LINE. I AM CAN
YOU GUYS HEAR ME OKAY YES WE
CAN HEAR YOU YOU MAY BEGIN
PLEASE. OKAY YEAH MY NAME'S TIM
SHELTON- MEMBERS RIGHT HERE IN
SACRAMENTO WE OPERATE THE
LARGEST ELECTRIC SCHOOL BUS
FLEET IN NORTH AMERICA WE
CURRENTLY HAVE FORTY AND WE'RE
MOVING- I HAD TO HAVING FIFTY
EIGHT. BUT I WILL TELL YOU THE
STRUGGLE TO DO THAT- FOR MOST
DISTRICTS IS GOING TO BE HUGE
CHALLENGE BECAUSE WE HAVE A
NAVIGATE THROUGH CARBON. OUR
LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS- THE CDC
DEAR FUNDING ON THE FEDERAL
SIDE H. FEB WE HAVE TO WORK
WITH VENDORS TO PROCURE ALL OF
THE VEHICLES CREATOR OWNED BIDS
IT'S REALLY AN OVERWHELMING
TASK FORCE SMALLER DISTRICTS.
AND I FEEL THAT THIS
LEGISLATION IS REALLY- WILL
MOVE THE INDUSTRY IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AND WILL BE VERY
HELPFUL FOR A SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND PUBLIC ENTITIES- SO I DO
FEEL IT'S A MUST THEY DO THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO- TO
PUT IN TO BRING THIS FORWARD
AND- I HOPE TO HEAR YET SO.
THANK THANK YOU SIR FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY SEEN ON HERE IN THE
ROOM WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF TO TURN TO A REMOTE
LOCATION I DON'T SEE ANYBODY
THERE AS WELL EITHER. SO WITH
THAT- MADAME MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES FOR
CALLERS IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
PLEASE. THANK YOU LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN. SUPPORT OF. AB ELEVEN TEN.
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THE TIME. AND WE'LL START WITH
BLIND SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. NINE SIXTY FIVE. AND
VINAYAN WE'LL GO TO LINE SIXTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
THAT YOU LIED MALINOVSKY PAUL
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ELECTRIC TRANSPORTATION
COALITION IN SUPPORT OF ELEVEN
TEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU OUR
NEXT PLEASE. NINE SIXTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. A GOOD MORNING
WHICH CHAIRED MEMBERS ADAM
KIANA SOME WE HAVE TO BE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES ALSO IN SUPPORT. Q.
NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU NECKLACE
NINE THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING SURE
NUMBERS ERIN RODRIGUEZ UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANKS
PLEASE. THANK THANK YOU MESSAGE
NINE SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
PATRICK WHAT'S WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WE HAVE NINE
SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
JR MEMBERS WE FIND CHECK WITH
SELLER BUT IT'S AN ASSOCIATE ON
BEHALF OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND THAT IS ALL THAT
I HAVE. TAKEN LESS TIME THANK
YOU. THANK YOU LET'S TURN TO
OPPOSITION THERE'S NO REGISTER
OPPOSITION SO- ANYONE HERE IN
THE ROOM WHO LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL PLEASE
RAISE YOUR HAND. YOU SEE NO
ONE. LET'S TURN TO A REMOTE
LOCATION I DON'T SEE ANYONE
EITHER SO-MADAME MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES
FOR THOSE. OF CALLERS- IN
OPPOSITION ON TO THIS BILL
PLEASE. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AB
ELEVEN TEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN THE
BILL NUMBERS AB ELEVEN TEN. YOU
IN ONE MOMENT- LINE NUMBER. WE
HAVE SPEAKER ON MY NUMBER FORTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THERE-
ACTION IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL-
STEVEN JIMENEZ WITH AMERICAN
LUNG ASSOCIATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. AND THAT
IS ALL THAT WE HAD. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH LET'S BRING BACK TO
OUR COMMITTEE QUESTION MR
BARNHART. I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR THIS IS ANOTHER GREAT
INNOVATIVE BILL I REMEMBER
SITTING ON THE ANTHONY CITY
COUNCIL WE WERE TRYING TO GET
CLEAN VEHICLE FLEETS. AND I
THINK OUR FIRST STAFF REPORT
CAME BACK AND SAID WE COULDN'T
DO IT AND I THINK EXACTLY WHAT
YOU'RE WITNESSES TESTIFIED TO
THAT IT'S VERY DIFFICULT FOR
SMALL AND IN A SPECIAL
DISTRICTS. TO HOW THAT
TECHNICAL KNOW HOW TO FOR STAFF
TO EVEN GO AND SAY THESE ARE
OPTIONS IN THE STATE SUPER
IMPORTANT I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT
THE BILL AND I THINK I'VE
ALREADY MOVED IT SO GOOD JOB
GOOD WORK I HOPE TO SEE THIS GO
ALL THE WAY TO THE GOVERNOR'S
DESK. EMISSIONS MEDICAL HAD
PLEASE. THANKS FOR BEING A PART
NOT NECESSARILY A FAN OF
EXECUTIVE ORDERS IN GENERAL ALL
THAT STUFF. BUT THIS IS COMING
UP QUANTIFIED MOVING IT
FORWARD. FOR RURAL COMMUNITIES
LIKE HAS BEEN SPOKEN EARLIER.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE EXPERTISE
THEY DON'T EVEN HAVE THE STAFF
TO GO AFTER TO LOOK AT THESE.
BUT THE BEST PART OF LIKE ABOUT
THIS IS THE FINANCING TO HELP
THEM GET THERE. SO WELL MY
FIGURES MOTION AGO HAD SECOND.
AND WE'LL MOVE IT ON. THANK
REGGAE SCENE COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS THAT WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE DISTRICT OF ACTS FOR
AN AYE VOTE VERY ATTENTIVE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
IT IS ITEM TEN AB ONE ONE ONE
ZERO THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
VICE CHAIR CUNNINGHAM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH HI SIR
BOERNER HORVATH I STILL LIVE A
RECAP I REMEMBER CHECK OUT HI
SOME OF OUR FUTURE NORRIS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SMITH. SO OVERSTAFFED I.
WHAT'S THE BILL CYCLE. I WOULD-
I SEE MR COOLEY WELCOME IS
COOLEY. MR COOLEY HAS ITEM
ELEVEN AND THAT'S E. B.
FOURTEEN FORTY SEVEN. AND
ANYTIME YOU'RE READY MISTER
COLLEY HER GOOD ARE. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'M
HERE TODAY TO PRESENT A B.
FOURTEEN FORTY SEVEN THE RURAL
CALIFORNIA INFRASTRUCTURE ACT.
ARM AND I DEFINITELY WANT TO
NOTE I. ACTUALLY I'VE HAD A
LONG CAREER WORKING WITH TONY
SIMONS WE GO BACK TO THE
ASSEMBLY BACK IN THE NINETIES
LATE EIGHTIES. ARE SHE HAS
CEMEX ON AMENDMENTS I WANNA
TAKE THEIR SET UP AND NOT
NUMBER FIVE- I WANT TO SAY IS
LAWMAKERS. WE PASS STATUTES ALL
THE TIME OF GENERAL APPLICATION
BECAUSE A THEY WORK ACROSS A
BROAD FRONT. THE CONCERN I HAVE
IN CALIFORNIA IS THAT WE HAVE
CERTAIN COUNTY PRINCIPALLY
RURAL. THAT HAVE SEEN
PERSISTENT NO GROWTH DRIVEN
DECLINES IN GROWTH. OF THESE
ARE FREQUENTLY RESOURCE RICH
COUNTIES THINGS LIKE THAT. I
THINK IT IS RIGHT FOR US IN
SACRAMENTO AS LAWMAKERS TO JUST
TAKE NOTE OF THESE MEMBERS OF
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY. THE
FAC DIFFERENT CHALLENGES WHEN
THEY TRY TO PUT TOGETHER
RESOURCES FOR CRITICAL LOCAL
IMPROVEMENTS THAT AFFECT PUBLIC
SAFETY DISASTER RESPONSE
COMMUNITY LIFE. AND THIS BILL
IS REALLY DESIGNED TO FOCUS ON
THOSE CLASS OF COUNTIES. AND IT
IS NOT CLEAR FOR US IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO DIRECT ITS
SPECIAL ATTENTION BE GIVEN TO
THEIR CIRCUMSTANCES. AND THEIR
ABILITY TO KIND OF RENEW
THEMSELVES ADDRESS CRITICAL
LOCAL ISSUES SO THAT THE
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE ENTIRE
STATE IS CLEAR EVEN IF THEY'RE
A RURAL COUNTY FACING DIFFERENT
NEEDS THERE ARE MORE URBAN
AREAS. ON TONY IS DONE A GREAT
SERVICE BY KIND OF TAKEN THIS
IDEA AND FITTED INTO THE HIGH
UNDERSTOOD. AND HAS A CLEARER
IN ORDER IS THE AVOID
REINVENTING THE WHEEL IS KIND
OF HOW I VIEW IT FOR VERY VERY
HELPFUL AMENDMENTS ON GOING
FORWARD I LOOK TO JUST CONTINUE
MY CONVERSATION WITH THE
REGIONAL COUNCIL RURAL COUNTIES
IN C. SACK IN THE LEAGUE OF
CITIES. TO MAKE SURE THAT AS WE
TRY TO GIVE SOME DIRECTION TO
HELP SUPPORT THESE PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA THAT WE REALLY
REFINED IS WHO IS PROTECTING
WELL ADAPTED THEIR NEEDS LIKE I
DO SORT OF HAVE AN ONGOING
INTEREST I AM A CO AUTHOR ON
THIS BILL WITH FRANK BIGELOW-
AND- SO ESERVER SERVE A
BIPARTISAN APPROACH TO USE
ELECTRIC POWER TO. GIVE SOME
GUYS TO THE STATE. ON SO
ACTUALLY THAT AGAIN I JUST
THANKED THE COMMITTEE. FOR THE
AMENDMENTS. FROM AND ARM. I
WILL JUST TURN IT OVER BACK TO
THE CHAIR FOR ANY TEST WHEN YOU
HAVE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISS COOLEY ARE YOU
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS IN THE
ANALYSIS YES INDEED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH BEFORE WE GO TO A
WITNESSES SO LET US SELL ALSO
OF- THE FOR THE COLLEGE THE
NUMBER TO CALL IS 877-692-8957
AGAIN THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN. SAY WITHOUT THEY'LL LET
US GO TO OUR WITNESS WE HAVE MR
JEFF NEAL FROM C. S. A. C.
MISTER NEIL ARE YOU ON THE LINE.
M. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR CHECK
DEAL HERE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES.
M. A LITTLE KNOWN SECRET
CALIFORNIA'S TAX SYSTEM AND
THAT I'M GONNA LET YOU GUYS IN
ON IS THAT EVER SINCE THE GREAT
RECESSION EVEN AS THE STATE'S
REVENUES HAVE EXPERIENCED
RECORD GROWTH. BUT PER CAPITA
GENERAL FUND REVENUES IN A
SURPRISING NUMBER OFCOUNTIES
HAVE ACTUALLY BEEN FLAT OR EVEN
DECLINED IN REAL DOLLARS OVER
THE PAST DECADE OVER THE COURSE
OF AN ENTIRE BUSINESS CYCLE IT
IS NOT REALLY THE WAY IT'S
SUPPOSED TO WORK. AT THE
COMMUNITIES THAT THIS BILL
WOULD BENEFIT IN PARTICULAR
HAVE BEEN NARAL TAX BASIS
COMPARED TO A LARGE URBAN AREA
BUT THEY BEAR THE BRUNT OF
CALIFORNIA'S NATURAL DISASTERS
BOTH EMOTIONALLY AND
FINANCIALLY AND ALL THESE
NATURAL DISASTERS ARE ARE
DEVASTATING TO THE SMALLER
COMMUNITIES THEY AFFECT ALL OF
US. AS WE'VE ALL SEEN OVER THE
PAST FEW YEARS SO IT'S
COMPLETELY APPROPRIATE FOR THE
STATE TO PROVIDE A SIGNIFICANT
RESOURCES WE THINK TO HELP
PREPARE FOR AND RECOVER FROM
THESE DISASTERS WE'VE SEEN OUR
WATER SYSTEMS DECIMATED WE'VE
SEEN ROADS AT THE NEEDS TO BE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT- AND SO
FOR ALL THESE REASONS WE DO
SUPPORT AB FOURTEEN FORTY SEVEN
THANK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY MISTER NEAL OF
SEE NO ONE HERE IN THE ROOM WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
LET'S TURN TO A REMOTE LOCATION
I DON'T SEE ANYBODY THERE
EITHER. SO WITH THAT- MADAME
MODERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN
OF THE PHONE LINES FOR THOSE
WHO LIKE TO CALL IN TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL AGAIN THE BILL NUMBER.
IS AB FOURTEEN FORTY SEVEN. YOU
TO SHARE SUPPORT FOR BI FORTY
FORTIES YOU MAY PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED ZERO. AGAIN THAT'S ONE
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
PLEASE. THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
LINE IN Q. ONE MOMENT.
AS WE
WAIT FOR THAT LINE IF THERE ARE
ANY OTHER LINES OF MY TEACHER
THEIR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL YOU
MAY ALSO PRESS ONE AND THEN THE
ZERO. MY NUMBER IS SIXTY TWO
SIX TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. AT
THIRTY DIFFERENT FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
MICRO ENTERPRISE OPPORTUNITIES
PART. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE
THANK YOU NO OTHER LINE THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OUT LET'S TURN TO
OPPOSITION I DON'T SEE ANY
REGISTER OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL SO- ANYONE HERE IN THE
ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION SEEING NONE- NOBODY
IS IN THE REMOTE LOCATION
EITHER. SO MR MODERATOR WOULD
YOU PLEASE OPEN UP THE PHONE
LINES AGAIN TO HIS- FOR ANY ONE
WHO LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL AGAIN BILL NUMBERS
A. B. FOURTEEN FORTY SEVEN. TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
FOURTEEN FORTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AGAIN
THAT'S A POSITION OF
OPPOSITION. ME PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. DO NOT ALIGN
SECURE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU-
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM COMMUNITY MISTER SMITH GO
AHEAD PLEASE. THANK BOTH OF YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD WHAT
A NOVEL IDEA LIST GET PREPARED
BEFORE WE HAVE A CATASTROPHE IN
THE STATE. AND BE PREPARED AND
HELP THE RURAL COMMUNITIES AND
THE SMALLER OF COMMUNITIES IN
THE CALIFORNIA. SO I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU'RE CONSIDERING CO
AUTHORS OR AUTHORS I'D LOVE TO
BE ON IT. THANKS I THINK
ALREADY OVED HE BILL FORTY
TWO IT'S BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. MISTER PETRIE-NORRIS
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. AND
THANKS TO THE AUTHOR AB TWO
RECOGNIZING THAT THE UNIQUE ODD
NEEDS OF SEVERAL CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES- I DO HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS IF. FIRST IS WHAT IS
MISSING. WITHIN OUR CURRENT.
THERE THERE'S A LOT OF PROGRAM
RIGHT THAT DOLE OUT
INFRASTRUCTURE DOLLARS WE HAVE
A LOT OF COMMITTEES AND
COMMISSIONS HE'S WHAT IN YOUR
MIND IS MISSING- RIGHT NOW.
THAT NECESSITATES THE CREATION
OF AN NEW COMMITTEE AND THEN IS
IT YOUR- IS THE BILL PREDICATED
ON THE NOTION THAT RURAL
COUNTIES ARE NOT GETTING THEIR
FAIR SHARE. RIGHT NOW OF
INFRASTRUCTURE DOLLARS. OR IS
IT A DIFFERENT PRESCRIPTION
ARM. NUMBER ONE I THINK THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS MAKE USE
OF THE I. BANK SO WE'RE- IT IS
CORRECT THAT I PROPOSED A
DIFFERENT ENTITY BUT NOW WE'RE
ROLLING IT INTO FIFTEEN
ADMINISTRATOR FROM HER- WHICH I
BELIEVE FURTHERS EFFICIENCY AND
HELP SOMEONE TO KNOW GENERALLY
HOW THE PROGRAM WORKS. I THINK
THE QUESTION BECOMES THE-
ECONOMIC STRAITS THE THIRD
RURAL COUNTIES ARE IN MAY MAKE
IT HARDER FOR THEM TO BRING THE
RESOURCES OF THE TABLE TO
COMPLETE PROJECTS. SO I THINK
IT IS FAIR TO LOOK AT WHAT ARE
THE TYPICAL CIRCUMSTANCES OF
STATIC OR DECLINING POPULATION
COUNTIES- RESOURCE BASED
ECONOMIES ALTHOUGH THAT'S NOT
SET UP THE BILL WOULD SORT OF
CHARACTERISTIC OF THOSE. AW
THAT THEY MAY BE HAVING
DIFFICULTY ARE I KNOW- HERE IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY WHICH IS NOT
ONE OF THESE GUYS PUT HERE
SECOND COUNTY IN HERALD. THE
CAREER FAIR WHICH IS A FORM
COMMITTEE IN THE SOUTHERN PART
OF THE- COUNTY- I. HAD FOR MANY
YEARS MET IN A HERALD BAR. THE
HERALD BARNES STARTED OUT AS A
POLE BARN. JUST PUT A PULL
CORRECTIVE STRUCTURE. LATE IN
ITS LIFE THEY PUT IN A CONCRETE
PAD SO THAT HAD A FLOOR. BUT
IT'S AGENTS SORT OF FALLING
APART. AND IT'S NOT EVEN WELL
ADAPTED TO HOW DO YOU UPDATE A
POLE BARN- SO I THINK THAT
THERE THIS STAND FOR THE IDEA
THAT. THERE CAN BE FACILITIES
WHICH HAVE PLAYED A VITAL ROLE
TO CREATE A LIFE WHICH ARE
AGING AND FALLING APART. AND
THE ABILITY OF SMALLER
COMMUNITIES WITH THE KIND OF
POPULATIONS FOR HOW TO. FINANCE
THOSE SORTS OF THINGS IT'S
DIFFERENT THAN A MAJOR URBAN
AREA WHERE YOU CAN PUT TOGETHER
A LOT OF RESOURCES. ON CERTIFY
I ACTUALLY DO BELIEVE THAT
THERE IT'S NOT THAT THEY'RE NOT
GETTING THEIR FAIR SHARE. BUT
THE UNDERLYING ECONOMICS OF
THEIR- COMMUNITIES MAKE IT
HARDER TO FINANCE SOME OF THESE
THINGS. SO I THINK IT'S JUST A-
IT IS WHAT I THINK OF AS A
CLASS OF SPECIAL STATUTE TO
LOOK AND SAY IS THERE ARE SOME
IDENTIFIABLE CIRCUMSTANCE IN
OUR STATE. BACK THEN WILL BE IN
A CALIFORNIANS. THAT WE CAN
FASHION A PLAN. OF UNDER THE
AYE BANK APPROACH. THEY WILL
HAVE TO DOCUMENT WHAT THE NEED
IS WHAT THE PROGRAM IS HOW THEY
PLAN TO. OUR FULFILL THE NEED
IN THE COURTS OF THE STATUTES
PURPOSES SO THERE WILL BE A
STATE ADMINISTRATOR TO ENSURE
THAT THE DOLLARS ARE PROPERLY
APPLIED. BUT IT IS KIND OF
SAYING THAT THERE'S- A VERY
RURAL AREA AND OUR STATE MAY
HAVE DIFFERENT NEEDS. AT
DIFFERENT RESOURCES TO MEET
THOSE NEEDS. IT'S ALSO VALID
FOR THE RISKS INVOLVED I
SURVIVE SERVICES TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN ON THE STATE SIDE OF
STATE TO COMMISSION FOR
SEVERITY OF THE ALL THE STATE'S
CITIES DOLLARS A MEMBER. AND IN
THE PARLANCE OF DISASTER
RESPONSE YOU'RE SEEING NOW.
MORE DISCUSSION OF WATER
ALLUDED TO AS LILY PADS. SMALL
SPOTS WITHIN A BROADER
EXPERIENCE WHERE YOU KNOW WHEN
A DISASTER PEOPLE CAN CONVERGE.
I THINK THE LILY PAD MODEL IS
ALSO IN THE BACK OF MY MIND ON
THE DISASTER RESPONSE PIECE
HERE. ON YOU KNOW WHEN INTO
PARADISE FIRE A LARGE CHRISTIAN
MISSIONARY ALLIANCE CHURCH IN
PARADISE SERVED AS A STAGING
AREA. BECAUSE IT WAS A BIG
BUILDING WITH A HUGE PARKING
LOT. WAS KIND OF SAFE. RIGHT I
JUST THINK THEY HAVE PARTICULAR
CHALLENGES THIS BILL WILL HELP
THEM START TO MEET. AND IF YOU
WERE PITCHING A SPELL SAY NOT
TO. FIVE URBAN OR SUBURBAN
LEGISLATORS BETTER URBAN OR
SUBURBAN TAX PAYERS IS THE
PITCH TO THEM THAT WE NEED TO
INVEST A INCREASE SHARE. IN
INFRASTRUCTURE AND IN RURAL
COUNTIES BECAUSE THERE'S SOME
COMPELLING STATEWIDE INTEREST
FOR DOING SO OR YEAH ABSOLUTELY
I THINK WE ARE ONE STATE I
THINK IT IS A BI PARTISAN MOVE
ITS GOVERNING FOR THE WHOLE
STATE. FIVE AND INCREASE YOUR
ATTENTION IDEA BECAUSE ACTUALLY
COMPARED TO WHAT WE SPEND ON
THE ENTIRETY OF THE STATE. IT
IS DE MINIMUS YOU KNOW IT TO BE
NOT EVEN A PERCENTAGE POINT.
IT'LL BE SO MINOR. AND YET IT
WOULD MEET A TERRIFIC NEED AND
DONNA I THINK LONG TERM IT. I
RELATED TO MY CITY OF RANCHO
CORDOVA WE HAD A VERY ROUGH
ROUGH NEIGHBORHOOD. ARE IN
RANGE OF OVER THE KIDS ACTUALLY
REFERRED TO AS A GET OUT. AW
AND ONE OF THE STRATEGIC THINGS
WE DID WAS WE BOUGHT SOME LAND.
BUILT HOUSING FOR VULNERABLE
SENIORS ON THE SAME BLOCK AS
SOME OF THE OTHER. BAD STUFF
AND THAT PUBLIC INVESTMENT
ACTUALLY RELEASED ENERGY NEARBY.
AND SO YOU SORT OF GET THE FLY
WHEEL SPINNING WHEN YU PUT
SOME PUBLIC INVESTMENT AND INTO
AN AREA AND I THINK IN THE SAME
WAY AND RURAL AREAS OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SUPPORTING
NEEDED FACILITIES IMPROVEMENTS
TO SUPPORT OUR POPULATIONS
AREAS. IT'S YOU KNOW THERE ARE
PART OF OUR STATE. AND IF THIS
IS A TOOL WELL ADAPTED TO HELP
THEM MEET THEIR NEEDS AND
SUPPORT THEIR- COPULATION. THEN
IT ACTUALLY DOESN'T MATTER THAT
IT'S A LITTLE DIFFERENT TOOL
THAT WE TYPICALLY DO. YOU KNOW
MOST OF OUR BIG URBAN COUNTIES
THEY HAVE LOTS OF STREAMS OF
RESOURCES YOU CAN SORT OF PUT
TOGETHER AND AGENCIES PEOPLE
PARKER. YOU KNOW YOU CAN GET A
CITY CAN GET SMART YOU CAN GET
OF SAC STATE YOU GET A LOT OF
DIFFERENT PEOPLE KIND OF. PUT A
SHORT OF THE WHEEL BUT I DON'T
THINK THOSE RESOURCES. ARE
COMMON IN THESE AREAS AND SORTS
A LITTLE BIT OF A DIFFERENT
APPROACH. I UNDERSTAND THAT
THANK YOU THANK YOU MUCH OTHER
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. C. NINE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. I JUST THINK WILL
PROVIDE YOUR BEING HERE AND I
REQUEST YOUR RIVALS. I THINK OF
IN A TIME WHEN WE SEE SO MUCH
DIVISIVENESS. THIS IS ACTUALLY
GOOD TONIC FOR TIME TO STAND UP
AND- FUNCTION AS AN ENTIRE
STATE. BUT ALSO RESPECTING THE
TOOLS THAT WE'VE DEVELOPED AND
HONED OVER TIME FOR AGAIN TONY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ASSISTANCE.
ACTUALLY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT STOP FOR THE BILL IS
APPROPRIATIONS MADAM SECRETARY
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ITEM ELEVEN AB ONE FOUR FOUR
SEVEN THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
VICE CHAIR CUNNINGHAM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH HER
RIGHT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH S. AS SUCH HI
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAD HI
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHECK OUT I AM
A REPEAT YOU NORRIS. SOME
REMEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS HI
DELIVER RAMOS. SILVA RAMOS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SPENT. SUMMERS
WITH I. YOU HAVE VOTES THE
BILL'S UP TO CONGRATULATE THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE. OUR NEXT SO
WE HEALTH. ITEM FOURTEEN THAT'S
AB NINE FIFTEEN THAT'S- MISSED
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO. AND BEFORE
HE BEGINS I LIKE TO REMIND THE
CALLERS TO CALL IN NUMBER IS.
877-692-8957 SO WELCOME
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS SHOOT AND-
LET'S SEE I UNDERSTAND YOU'LL
BE ACCEPTING THE COMEDIAN
AMENDMENTS IDENTIFIED IN COMMON
NINE OF THE BILL ANALYSIS IS
ACCURATE YES OF COURSE VERY
GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WITH
THAT THE PLEASE BEGIN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR LET ME JUST
START BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR AMENDMENTS- THAT
AMONG OTHER THINGS HELP INSURE
THAT BUSINESSES ARE COMPETITIVE
APPLICANTS FOR STATE CONTRACTS.
AND CREATE A FAST TRACK FOR
WITHIN DGS FOR BUSINESSES
CERTIFIED AS BABIES TO RECEIVE.
SMALL BUSINESS CERTIFICATIONS.
AB NINE FIFTEEN WILL HELP
CALIFORNIA LIVE UP TO OUR
PROMISE TO SUPPORT SMALL AND
DIVERSE BUSINESSES. OUR STATE
HAS ENORMOUS PURCHASING POWER
AND WE SHOULD USE THAT POWER TO
HELP SMALL BUSINESSES DURING
THIS PANDEMIC CAN BE ON. THE
HEART OF THIS BILL ESTABLISHES
A 25% DETERMINED GOAL FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES AND TAKE STEPS TO
MAKE STATE CONTRACTING MORE
ACCESSIBLE. TO SMALL DIVERSE
BUSINESSES. THIS IS BASED ON AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER SIGNED BY
FORMER GOVERNOR SCHWARZENEGGER
IN TWO THOUSAND SIX.
ESTABLISHING A GOAL FOR ALL
STATE AGENCIES THAT 25% OF
CONTRACTS SHOULD GO TO SMALL
BUSINESSES. UNFORTUNATELY THAT
EXECUTIVE ORDER WAS IGNORED. OF
THE TWO HUNDRED THIRTY ONE
STATE AGENCIES DEPARTMENTS AND
COMMISSIONS ONLY TWELVE HAVE
ADOPTED A SMALL BUSINESS. OR
DISABLED VETERANS BUSINESS
PRICE POLICY. THIS BILL
CODIFIES THAT GOAL INTO LAW.
AND MANDATES THAT AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS BE AUDITED IF THEY
DON'T MEET THAT 25% THRESHOLD
BY TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN. THIS
BILL ALSO LOOKS AT SMALL
BUSINESS REVIVAL THROUGH EQUITY
LINES BY CREATING AND ECONOMIC
EQUITY FIRST POLICY. THE CRAZY
DEFINITION WHICH IS CONSISTENT
WITH FEDERAL LAW FOR
DISADVANTAGED BUSINESS
ENTERPRISES OTHERWISE KNOWN AS
DVDS. DEFINED AS WOMAN LGBTQ.
AND MINORITY OWNED SMALL
BUSINESSES. SMALL BUSINESSES
DID DISADVANTAGED VETERAN
BUSINESS ENTERPRISES AND DVDS
WITH ALL BE INCLUDED IN THE 25%
PROCUREMENT TARGET. LASTLY
SINCE APPLYING FOR STATE
CONTRACTS CAN BE VERY DIFFICULT
THIS BILL ALSO REQUIRES THE
STATE TO MAKE A LIST OF STATE
AGENCY SMALL BUSINESS LIAISONS.
ON THANK A COALITION
REPRESENTING MANY SMALL
BUSINESSES AS WELL AS ETHNIC
CHAMBERS AROUND THE STATE AND
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO BRING UP
DAVID NELSON. WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASIAN CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE. AS OUR FIRST WITNESS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
NELSON YOU MAY BEGIN. MISS
NELSON ARE YOU ON THE LINE.
RIGHT HERE BOTH IN PERSON HOW
ABOUT THAT RIGHT. RIGHT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING HERE
WITH US YOU MAY BEGIN BY THE
SUIT ITSELF THAT THAT YOU'RE
YOU'RE NOT BEING IN HERE SELL-
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE AND THANK
YOU MY NAME IS DAVID NELSON I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC POLICY
FOR THE CALIFORNIA ASIAN
PACIFIC CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IT
HAS BEEN MY HONOR TO WORK WITH
MEMBER CHIU AS WELL AS HOLDEN
AND HER FELLOW CO SPONSORS THE
CALIFORNIA AFRICAN AMERICAN
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND THE
CALIFORNIA SPENDING CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN DRAFTING THIS MUCH
NEEDED AND LONG OVERDUE PIECE
OF LEGISLATION. THE PRINCIPLES
AND DELIVERABLES OF ASSEMBLY
BILL NINE ONE FIVE HAVE LONG
BEEN OVERDUE. FOR THE SMALL AND
MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. ORIGINALLY WE
DRAFTED THIS BILL WITH INTENT
OF CODIFYING THE TWENTY FIVE
PERCENT. SMALL BUSINESS PICTURE
MICHAEL THAT IS MEMBER CHIU
ALLUDED TO AS EXISTED. IN
EXECUTIVE ORDER FORMAT SINCE
TWO THOUSAND SIX. BUT IS
LONGLEY AS LONG REMAIN VIRTUOUS
AS IS NOT BEEN IN STATUTE AND
THEREFORE NO REAL
ACCOUNTABILITY EXISTS FOR THE
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER. TO
ACQUIRE THOSE CONTRACTS. SADLY
THIS LAST YEAR HAS GREATLY
EXASPERATED WHAT WE IN THE
MINORITY BUSINESS COMMUNITY
HAVE KNOWN FOR FAR TOO LONG.
THE MINORITY AND DISADVANTAGED
BUSINESS OWNERS BEAR THE LION'S
SHARE OF DISPARITY AND LACK OF
ACCESS. AB NINE ONE FINDS NINE
ONE FIVE FUNDAMENTALLY
ADDRESSES THIS CONCERN BY
REQUIRING STATE AGENCIES. TO
DEVELOP WHAT WE CALL ECONOMIC
EQUITY FIRST ACTION PLANS.
THESE ACTION PLANS SHALL FOCUS
ON EDUCATING DISADVANTAGED
BUSINESS ENTERPRISES AND BRING
THEM INTO STATE PROCUREMENT
PIPELINE. DELIVERING MUCH
NEEDED ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES
TO OUR MOST IMPACTED BUSINESS
COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WE ALL KNOW. THAT
NOT ONLY WILL SMALL BUSINESSES
STRUGGLE TO REBOUND FROM THE
DEVASTATING ECONOMIC EFFECTS OF
THIS LAST YEAR. BUT MANY IN OUR
DISADVANTAGED BUSINESS
COMMUNITIES WILL BE THE LAST TO
RECOVER. IF THEY RECOVER AT ALL.
AND I JUST WANTED TO SHARE IN
CLOSING- AS I WAS WALKING INTO
THE STATE CAPITOL TODAY I JUST
COULDN'T HELP BUT THINK THAT-
YOU KNOW IT'S EASY FOR US TO
LOOK OVER STATISTICS AND-
REPORTS AND POLL NUMBERS AND
SEE. WHAT WE HAVE KNOWN THAT
DISPARITY TRULY EXIST IN OUR
BUSINESS COMMUNITIES. AND THAT
THOSE PEOPLE DO LIVE ON THE
MARGINS. BUT I WOULD PROPOSE TO
YOU THAT ALL OF US IN THIS
ROOM. ARE NOT IN THAT MARGIN.
THEY ARE IN THE MARGIN. AND
THEY LIVE IN THAT MARGIN EVERY
SINGLE DAY. AND WON THE
CONTRACT. CAN MAKE THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN DINNER. AND
PAYING PAYROLL AND MAYBE DOING
BOTH AT THE SAME TIME. AND SO
WE STRONGLY ENCOURAGE YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL FOR THE
SAKE OF ALL SMALL BUSINESSES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO ARE
MINORITY INTO SAID
DISADVANTAGED THROUGHOUT OUR
STATE SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR IPHONE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR IN
PERSON TESTIMONY SO IT'S SO
DIFFERENT AND SO REFRESHING TO
HAVE FIFA VERY FIRST EFFECT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUR NEXT-
WITNESS WE HAVE MISSED A
LAWRENCE CHAU. A WHO IS THE
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF FOB
AND TIVITY I BELIEVE YOU ARE
MISTER ARE YOU ON THE LINE. I
AM PLEASED AGAIN YES. RIGHT
THANK YOU I THANK EVERYBODY FOR
HAVING ME AND ALSO- FOR GIVING
ME AN OPPORTUNITY TO YOU GUYS
AND SHARE MY OPINION- MY NAME
IS MARK CHAU UNDER FOUNDER AND
CEO OF AN ONLINE PRETTY COMPANY
BASED HERE IN SAN DIEGO CALLED
TIVITY- OPPORTUNITY WE DESIGNED
A PRINT MARKETING AND
PROMOTIONAL PRODUCTS HELP SMALL
BUSINESSES AND ENTREPRENEURS
GROW- WE HAVE OVER SIXTY
EMPLOYEES- WE'VE SERVED OVER
FORTY THOUSAND CUSTOMERS.
FAMILIES ALSO- RATHER THAN I
WOULD WANT BUT THAT ONE. FOR
FASTEST PER COMPANY IN AMERICA.
THREE TWO. THE FOUNDER OWNER I
KNOW FIRST HAND CHALLENGE OF
GROWING BUSINESS SCRATCH I
ACTUALLY STARTED PRODUCTIVITY
IN MY MOTHER'S GARAGE WITH LESS
THAN TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS TO MY
NAME. I THINK ACTUALLY STILL
OVER A LITTLE BIT OF RENT FOR
THAT- WE HAVE SHOULD NEVER HAD
ANY INVESTORS OR LOANS WE HAVE
POOR BUSINESS. BY TAKING CARE
OF ONE CUTS READY TIME- YOU
KNOW ONE TWENTY ALL ORDER THE
TIME ONE THIRTY DOLLAR ORDER
AND TIME. AND JUST KIND. OF
STEPPED UP ON MONEY- FOR THE
ENTIRE. OF BUSINESS- I'VE MET
AND SPOKEN SO MANY SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS AND
ENTREPRENEURS AND- YOU KNOW
THEY ARE SOME OF THE BIGGEST
TRIMMING AND HARDEST WORKING
INDIVIDUAL BOB MATT. ON BOTH
ONE THING THAT WE ALL HAVE IN
COMMON IS. THAT WE WANT TO
GIVEN AN EQUAL CHANCE TO
SUCCEED. I THINK SMALL
BUSINESSES HAVE BEEN HIT PRETTY
MUCH THE HARDEST BY COVERT
NINETEEN- A LOT OF US HAVE HAD
TO CLOSE OUR DOORS TAKE ON DEBT
AND EVEN COMPLETELY CHANGE
THEIR BUSINESS MODELS IN ORDER
TO SURVIVE- REALLY ANXIOUS. FOR
THE COMIC RECOVERY- WE'RE
REALLY ANXIOUS TO BRING
STABILITY TO OUR EMPLOYEES AND
WERE REALLY ANXIOUS TO BEGIN
SERVING THE PUBLIC AGAIN. THE
WAY WHERE ARE USED TO DOING.
EIGHTY NINE ONE FIVE HELP SMALL
BUSINESSES MINORITY AND
DISADVANTAGED BETTER BUSINESS
SAYS- PARTICIPATE IN THE STATE
PROCUREMENT AND CONTRACTS
THAT'S A BIG DEAL TO US. THAT
BRINGS EXPOSURE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY TO ALLOW THE
STATE'S PLEDGE MEETING ABOUT
25% PROCUREMENT CALL.
HISTORICALLY SPEAKING I AM A
MINORITY BUSINESS OWNER BUT
HISTORICALLY SPEAKING MINORITY
OWNED SMALL BUSINESSES.
GENERALLY HAVEN'T REALLY
BENEFITED FROM STATE
PROCUREMENT CONTRACTS- WE KNOW
THAT THESE CONTRACTS ARE REAL
WE JUST DON'T THINK THAT THE
REALISTIC. FOR ME AND FOR A LOT
OF US EIGHTY NINE POINT FIVE
CHANGES THAT- AB NINE ONE FIVE
TELLS US THAT WE HAVE A SEAT AT
THE TABLE. HELP US THAT THESE
OPPORTUNITIES ARE REAL. AND IT
COMES AT A TIME WHEN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA TWO YEARS SINCE
ALMOST UNPARALLELED. TREMENDOUS
PURCHASING POWER HELPS
SUBMITTED SMALL BUSINESSES HAVE
BEEN DEVASTATED BY COVERED
NINETEEN. SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
LIKE MYSELF I'M NOT AFRAID OF
HARD WORK. WE REALLY JUST WANT
TO BE GIVEN A CHANCE TO SHOW
YOU WHAT WE CAN DO. SO WITH
THAT I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU GUYS
AGAIN FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE MY THOUGHTS AND I
SINCERELY HOPE YOU THEIR
SUPPORT. AB NUMBER FIVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY ANYONE ELSE HERE IN
THE ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
C. NINE NOBODY IN THE REMOTE
LOCATION WHAT IS THERE EITHER
SO WITH THAT- MISTER MODERATOR
WHICH PLEASE OPEN UP THE PHONE
LINES. FOR CALLERS IN SUPPORT
OF AB NINE FIFTEEN. THANK YOU
TO STATE YOUR SUPPORT FOR A BI
NINE FIFTEEN ME PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON YOUR PHONE
THAT WAS ONE TEN ZERO. GO TO
OUR FIRST LINE IN Q. TO SIX
EIGHT SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BUT MORNING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THE TECHNICIAN ALL DAY
LONG BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER. COURT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
NINE SEVENTY TWO ONE SEVEN TWO.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS EDWIN
LOMBARD PRESIDENCY OF THE
CALIFORNIA AMERICAN CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE BUT WE'RE HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB NINE
FIFTEEN THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HACKSPACE BLAMES. NINE SIXTY
SEVEN SIX SEVEN. HOLLY FOR MANY
ENDING AT THE WITH THE WHITE
HOUSE PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF
OF BLACK LEADERSHIP COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. BACKSPACE.
NINE FIFTY NINE FIVE NINE. GOOD
MORNING MANY THE SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
HISPANIC CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
VERY MUCH SUPPORT AND PROP CO
SPONSOR THANK YOU. NEXT PLACE.
ONE SEVENTY ONE SEVEN ONE. NINE
SEVENTY ONE OF YOUR PHONE ON
MUTE. GO TO THE NEXT LINE WITH
THE LINE. SEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT.
RECORDING A VERDICT BE A LOT
CRUISE WITH STRATEGIES ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA BOARD
AT FUN IN FRONT SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THANKS WE'VE-
ONE SEVENTY SO FOUR. FIVE NINE
MY IS BEYOND THAT MANAGED
CALIFORNIA POLICY A SMALL
BUSINESS MAJORITY WE ARE
NATIONAL BUSINESS. MANPOWER
AMERICA MANTRA NORTH ABOUT THE
THRIVING AND AQUICK ECONOMY AND
STRONG OF AB NINE THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANKS FOR
POOL. EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHT ZERO.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBER OF THE OF THE AMITY THIS
IS A LOT ABOUT ON BEHALF OF THE
OFFENSE OF DEVELOPMENT. A
NONPROFIT THROUGHOUT- OF
CALIFORNIA WITH ON THE GROUND
IN HERE FROM THE AND WE ARE IN
OF AB NINE ONE FIVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANKS PLACE. THANK
NINE TWENTY EIGHT TWO. HELLO
CONNIE CHAN ON BEHALF OF KOAT
STATE KIANA MAILLET CALLING THE
PORT FOUR EIGHT NINE FIFTY
THANK THANK YOU. NEXT WE HAVE A
SEVEN NINE SEVEN. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS ROLLED CITY COUNCIL
PROJECT SEVEN THE CITY OF DIEGO
CHAIRMAN OF THE CITY OF
ECONOMIC TO IN INTER RELATIONS
COMITTEE CALLING AND SO OF AB
NINE MONTHS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. NINE EIGHT TWO
EIGHT. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS ASSIST HER ONE
REPRESENTING THE CO A SMALL AND
TO SAVE VETERAN BUSINESS IN
STRONG BUT AB FIFTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WHAT SO SIX SEVEN
ONLINE THE- YES GOOD SHARE AND
MEMBER THIS IS LAURIE KAMMER
WITH BUSINESS CAL. AND ALSO THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF WHEN
BUSINESS OWNERS CHAPTER HE
STRONG THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
LINE. SEVENTY SEVEN SEVEN
SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
PAT FONG CRISTINA AND I'M
PREGNANT AND CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASIAN PACIFIC
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND IT HAS
BEEN ARE HONORED TO WORK WITH
MEMBER CHIU AND HOLDEN EIGHTY
NINE AND I'M- PROUD TO WORK ON
THE FILM MICHAEL AND WOOD
MUMBAI IN JULY CAN ANY FROM THE
CAL. AFRICAN CHAMBER COMMERCE
THANK SPENDING CHAMBER COMMERCE
WE WORK HI NOT ONLY BY THE BILL
TOGETHER SUPPORT AND WORK WITH
STAFF TO ENSURE THAT THIS
EFFECTIVELY EFFICIENTLY ALL
SMALL BIZ IN THE STATE AS WELL
TO CREATE MORE PATH FROM
DISADVANTAGE BUSINESS OWNERS AT
TO TAKE AND- THANK YOU OVER THE-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OUR FINAL
LANDING Q. LINE FIFTH SIX FIVE
SO ZERO ONE IS OPEN. IN FIFTY
SIX DID WANT TO STATE YOUR-
TURN OFF FOR THEM IN Q. AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU LET'S TO OFF.
THERE'S REGISTER TO THIS BILL
SO IT DOES- I DON'T SEE ANY IN
THE ROOM WHO TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION IT'S TURNED TO A
REMOTE LOCATION. ARE SEEN NONE
OF LETTUCE- OPEN OF THE PHONE
LINE MISTER A MODERATOR FOR
CALLERS IN OPPOSITION TO THE B.
NINE FIFTEEN. AS STATED IF
YOU'D LIKE TO. RAISE YOUR
OPPOSITION TO AB NINE FIFTEEN
ME PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
ON YOUR PHONE THAT'S ONE ZERO
PROPOSITION OF NINE FIFTEEN.
FOR THE FIRST TIME SIXTY TWO
SIX TWO. YEAH APOLOGIES I
THOUGHT I WAS IN LINE FOR
SUPPORT WHO- NINE FIFTEEN TITLE
PICKMAN FROM CAMEO CALIFORNIA
SINCE HM FOR MICRO ENTERPRISE
OPPORTUNITY STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB. NINE ONE FIVE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ASSEMBLY SORT FIFTH
SIX. LINE. FIVE SIX. NINE FIFTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN ALLIANCE-
THEY'RE NOT FOR THE LINE SECURE
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR FURTHER DISCUSSION ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. BOB AND
IT YOU FIRST QUARTER I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR THIS BILL-
YOU KNOW I FOR WE SPOKE A LOT
OF TIME MAKING CALL AND THEN
DON'T SPEND A TIME IN. THAT ITS
EMPLOYMENT INSIDE APPRECIATE
THE NUANCE THAT YOUR BILL
BRINGS AND HAPPY TO SUPPORT
TODAY MOVED ABOUT THANK YOU
MISTER PETER NORRIS YEAH I
WOULD JUST ADD. THANK YOU FOR
BRING THIS BILL FOR I'VE TO SAY
I JUST TO BETTER AT THAT IS
MORE THAN OF OUR AGENCY HAVE OF
JUST IGNORED THE TWO THOUSAND
AND SIX EXECUTIVE ORDER FROM
GOVERNOR SORE. ALSO DISMAYED TO
SEE JUST HOW OFTEN. S. ARE
PROPOSALS. ODD TO THIS AND IT
AND TO SINCE YOU'D HAVE FAILED
AND HAVE. THEIR DIED QUITE THAT
THROUGH THE LET PROCESS TO
FIVE. HOPE THAT WE CAN CAN
DIFFERENT PASS OF YOUR- ON THE
WOULD LOVE TO ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR. THANK YOU FOR MUCH IF
THERE ARE NO. COMMENTS OAK- FOR
THE AUTHOR YOU LIKE TO. MISTER
WELL FIRST OF ALL REALLY PRETTY
THIS AND HAPPY TO ADD OUR CALLS
A COLD TO THE- LITTLE KNOWN-
PART OF MY PAST I SPENT DECADE
STARTING OVER. A SMALL BUSINESS
PER I RAN FOR A LOT OFFICE AND
SERVE AS A SMALL. COMMISSIONER
MICE. AND IN. IT IT IS. ALMOST
WERE DONE IN AN OBVIOUS TO THAT
ARE SMALL. AND ARE DIVERSE AND
SMALL BUSINESSES ARE THE
LIFEBLOOD OF OUR COMMUNITIES
OUR ECONOMY- BUT- WHAT HAS
ALWAYS BURKE ME FOR MANY YEARS
IS. GOVERNMENT PARTICULARLY
STATE GOVERNMENT WE SPEND
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND
PROCUREMENT. THE TYPICALLY GO
TO THE LARGEST COMPANIES IN THE
WORLD. THAT ARE PARTICULARLY
OFTEN NOT BASED IN OUR STATE.
WHERE WE COULD HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A PORTION
OF OUR PROCUREMENT. GO TO OUR
LOCAL AND DIVERSE BUSINESSES AS
ECONOMIC STIMULUS PARTICULARLY
DURING THIS TIME OF PANDEMIC IN
RECESSION SO. TO ME THIS IS A
NO BRAINER I REALLY WANT TO
THANK THE KALENJIN CHAMBER FOR.
PROPOSING THIS AND OF COURSE I
WANT TO THANK THE CAL HISPANIC
CHAMBER AND AFRICAN AMERICAN
CHAMBER. FOR WORKING ALONGSIDE
ALLOF US TO GET THIS DONE AND
APPRECIATE- YOUR I VOTED. THANK
YOU. IT'S BEEN A THE BILL HAS
BEEN AND SECONDED- MADAM
SECRETARY CUTS WITH TO PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL FOR US THIS IS
ITEM FOURTEEN EIGHTY NINE ONE
FIVE THE MOST IS A- DO PASS AS
OF TO. FIVE CHECK OUT ASSEMBLY
BOERNER HORVATH I SIMMER BURNER
HI MEMBER CHAD BY SUMMER CHECK
OUT HI SO ARE. HI SIR IF YOU I
SIMPLY REMOTE SUMMER RAMOS ICE
MEMBER. FILE ON FOUR IT IS ON
CALL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SO
THE WAS THE LAST BILL ON THE
AGENDA LET US- TAKE CARE OF THE
CONSENT AGENDA I LIKE TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADOPT
TODAY'S A CONSENT AGENDA. MADAM
OUR CONSULTANT SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT
AGENDA. THE CONSENT AGENDA IS
INCLUDES ITEM TO AB FOUR SEVEN
FIVE- THE MOTION IS DOABLE
PASSED THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS ITEM FIVE AB
ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE THE MOTION
IS A DO PASS TO ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
ITEM NINE AB ONE OH THREE SIX
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ITEM THIRTEEN AB
FIFTEEN SEVENTY THREE THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. ITEM FIFTEEN.
AB ONE OH SEVEN TWO THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ITEM FOR. AB SIX THREE ZERO THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED WITH
AMENDMENTS TO ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS AND
ITEM SIX AB EIGHT FOUR FOR THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED WITH
AMENDMENTS TO THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR. BYE FOR CUNNINGHAM I
THANK YOUR CUNNINGHAM I
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH.
SOME OF OUR BOERNER HORVATH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU. SO
REMEMBER JAIL SUMMER
PETRIE-NORRIS I SERVE
PETRIE-NORRIS LIBERADAS
SILVERADOS I STILL REMEMBER
SPENT SUMMER SMITH HI. WOULD BE
TIME TO CALL ABSENT MEMBERS ON
THE ITEMS ON CALL I CAN'T AT
THE COUNT CONTENT CALENDAR
COULD BE OUT- AT SIX. ON THE
CONSENT. GREAT DID I SAY
ANYTHING ELSE NO MY GOD OKAY.
OKAY I THINK IT'S TO DO ADAM IF
YOU COULD WITH ITEM ALLOW AB
FORTY SO. CALL ABSENT MEMBERS
PLEASE. THIS IS AN ADD ON-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VICE THEIR VICE
CHAIR CUTTING HI PRESSURE
COUNTY I. VOTERS SIX ZERO THE
BILL OUT. I THINK THE
ADDITIONAL DO WE NEED AT ON A
FORTY AB FIFTY BY MY CHIU THE
ONE ARE OF THE LAST ITEM ARE ON-
WITH THE LIFT THE CALL THAT
COULD BE THE WRONG THAT
POLITICS. WHY DON'T WE LIFT THE
CALL ON A- FORTY AND- FIFTEEN.
I HAVE I'D TEN FORTY AND THAT I
OPPOSE IF I HAVE YOU THE IN USE.
EARLIER IS PROBABLY MY FAULT
FOURTEEN AND- A SLIP CALL. THE
ITEM TEN AB ONE ZERO. BY SHARE
I BY STATE CUNNINGHAM I
ASSEMBLY MURPHY. SOME ARE
PETRIE-NORRIS I SAW US. FIVE
THAT IS SIX ZERO THAT OUT. THE
NEXT DAY IS I TWELVE IT'S A B.
ELEVEN OH. MEISTER COUNTY I'VE
REQUEST YOUR COUNTY I. ASSEMBLY
WERE PETRIE-NORRIS. HILLARY
NORRIS I AROUND ALL RIGHT SIR
RAMOS I AND- I PUBLIC I SHOULD
HAVE THAT THEY IS DUE PASSAGE
AMENDED TO A FROM. FOR A BI.
ELEVEN SIX- PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS I'M SORRY THAT
IS WHAT YOU ASK FOR THE
BEGINNING I WAS A COMPUTER FILE
PAPER WORK WORK WE'VE GOT
SURROUNDED. I DON'T FOURTEEN AB
NINE ONE FIVE. PFIZER
CUNNINGHAM I. AND THAT IS. SIX
ZERO THAT ITEM IS OUT AND
LESSEN MISTAKEN THAT CONCLUDES
OUR COMMITTEE HEARING THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.